but in that so you cross and sit on this
side where we have two other counselors
who can speak on applications in their
ward but may not vote so between the
eight of us or maybe one or two less who
have to cross the floor for a particular
item we all make decisions on the
applications before us and starting up
here on the right we have ian depresses
our legal advisor and then we have
officers who will present the
applications at the back we've got all
the nametags out today and Robert is the
person administers today and make sure
that everything flows in order so and
that's the way it's going to work and if
you are on the list to speak if you can
come up to the front and push the button
as a silver button you have three
minutes we do have a timer and we will
ask you to keep to the three minutes if
you're one of the speakers so moving
onward but just need to remind you of
some of the domestic arrangements the W
C's are situated outside the meeting
room opposite these stairs and there's a
cold water is also available in the
breakout area opposite outside the
meeting room if the fire alarm does
sound today can you please leave the
meeting room follow the fire exit signs
and we're together on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch and we
please do not come back into this
building until we've told you just safe
to do so can I also ask everyone please
to make sure their mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and if a
counsellors phone rings we always make a
5-pound donation to the Chairman's
charity I'd like to remind everyone
present this meeting is being broadcast
live on the internet and will be capable
of repeat viewings the whole of the
Milton meeting is being filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you'll be deemed by the
council to consented to being filmed and
to the possible use of those images and
the sound recordings for webcasting or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the press may record film
will photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and press
are not lawfully excluded can I just
remind members and officers that when
you do speak please press the microphone
on members you need to swipe your card
on the right hand side so that your name
comes up and when you finish please do
turn off the microphones they will now
move on to the agenda and the first item
on the agenda is apologies for absence
and substitutions please Thank You chair
we have today we have one substitution
of counselor Madison for counselor Byrne
next item item two to receive any
declarations of peculiar or non
pecuniary interest by members yes what
counsel will start this end counts are
having similar thank you chair I should
non-pecuniary interest for DC one nine
zero six six to land of land to the east
of poplar Hill I'm actually the vice
chair of the Stowe market Town Council
Planning Committee
anyone else yes I did yep thanks Jay
yeah non-pecuniary interest in DC 1900
six six two I signed the petition
against a proposal when I was a parish
councillor but not district councillor
as you can't vote yes council man sir I
thought perhaps I just better mentioned
that I am now a member of my parish
council and the case in Forli Crescent I
was not actually present at the parish
council meeting when they put their
comments in and just for clarity I'm the
when it comes to item number C in
Christianson Mary I am the county
councillor for greetings to Mary
okay anyway all the declarations I think
with that next item is any decorations
of lobbying to members yeah start this
end again cancer heading up and work
along
thank you yes I've had emails regarding
DC 1804 to 67 and also DC 19.00 301
similar issue emails I'm sure concerning
poplar here okay
thank you very much and next item on the
agenda item number four decorations of
personal site visits have only been
carried out nope
thank you next we move to item number
five and this is confirmation of the
minutes held on the meeting on the 13th
of March 2019 for those members here
that were part of that committee I just
slight amendment okay
Thank You members and just a very slight
amendment to the minutes on the
declarations of interest council having
them pointed out to me the other day
that there was an omission which has now
been added which raises it for me - yep
thank you which just raised council
lavinia having declared a non-pecuniary
interest in application DC 1805 o21 as
she knew the applicant which has been
added to the so that's the only change
okay
are we all happy those who here to sign
that there's true records have an
agreement that agreed yep
thank you I'll sign those afterwards
okay item number six on the agendas to
receive notifications of petitions in
accordance with the councillors petition
scheme do we have a name Thank You chair
we have one petition to report to
Council which has been reported reported
to the committee which it's already been
reported to the council and that is for
the applications the first application
this morning of DC 1966 to the land east
of poplar Hill this is signed by 1600
and 7 petitioners and reads and the
undersigned agree to the following
statement we the undersigned petition
the council to refused planning
application DC 1966 to land east of
poplar Hill as it will revert
irrevocable
irrevocably apologies damaged the
landscape surrounding grade 1 listed
some Mary's Church degrade the natural
and historic environment have a
detrimental impact on traffic and safety
but pressure on already overstretched
health care services and schools and
reduced a strategic gap between stone
market and the village of Koons thank
you thank you very much so we have
received that petition and that's all we
need to acknowledge at this stage thank
you
so we will stay with the order of we
can't we do sometimes move the agenda
around if needed but if we have large
number of people an item that's here
later on we try and bring that forward
because we will stay with the agenda
order so the first item is 7a is DC 1906
6-2 land to the east of poplar Hill snow
market in Suffolk and yep this is
application
0:06 62 land east of poplar Hill instant
snow market
this is the application site shown in
pink in front of us extends from stone
market down towards the village of
Coombs with poplar Hill running along
the edge of the site and we've got the
Church of sin Mary's which is on the
right-hand side of that plan but we'll
pick that out a bit further detail in
just a minute
so again this is the application site in
pink we can see to the north of the site
we're looking up to you Kim Jordans day
market and then to the south looking
down to the village of Coombs itself
again to the right-hand side of the
application site we're coming down
towards the church at Mary's zoomed in
view there again sites in pink you can
see the open countryside what you can't
quite see so well from that point of
view is the hill so just the north of
the site is essentially the crest of the
hill and then as we come south we come
down the hill looking essentially
through that part of this rolling Valley
and that of this site down towards the
village of Coombs and again we've got to
the right of the application site in
that area in green is the the church and
just a zoomed out for you there again
you can see the relationship the site
has currently being a area of separation
between stay market and village and
again just on the map form there the
proposal is for residential development
on the application sites there has been
a previous application on this site
which was refused the full reasons
refusal are set out in your papers at
the beginning of the report so I'm just
taking the page number on page 15 and 16
that application was for 160 dwellings
the proposals now been reduced to 138
dwellings the previous recent refusal
included because the land was on outside
assessment bans of stone markets and
it's considered to have harm to the
environment the objective thinking about
the natural and historic environment
particularly it's also
fused because of the impact and the site
as open countryside and how it
contributes to the significance of the
great one mr. Church because it imposes
built development into the open
countryside and because of harm to Kim's
would cite a special scientific interest
which is again on the right of the slide
up there
it was also refused that application
because of archaeological issues through
the course of that appeal the
archaeology issues have been resolved
through further assessment on site and
Suffolk County Council archaeology have
confirmed that they're happy for this to
be dealt with by condition now which
leaves us the four reasons refusal that
are being contested currently at appeal
I said this proposal does reduce the
number of dwellings and I think what
they're trying to do is provide a
greater separation between state markets
and homes
however as well go on to the photos in
just a second because we come over the
crest of the hill into the development
coming over there will be more visible
in the landscape and we'll still have an
impact and we still consider that it
would have an impact on the list of
building and consequently the four
reasons refusal that we had last time
we're still looking at saying that it's
the same situation here so I just
continue on from there so this is
popular Hill we've essentially got to
stay market away to our left and we're
looking down the valley and you can just
see the church in the center of that
photograph so as you can see we just
essentially on the crest of the hill
with the development just a market
falling right are left that's where I
write the valley falls away towards
Coombs which again then you can see this
we've got those houses behind us just on
the very edge of the current development
and we're looking with the applications
like to our left down poplar Hill across
towards the village and again just the
wider view where you can really get a
feeling for the rolling nature of that
area and again we're looking back there
towards the existing development on
Church Lane and that's the best view
down towards the hill that's right a
towards the church which as you can see
development there would be in it setting
and that's the reason why we consider it
would affect significance it was a very
rural church and the advice we've had
from historic England is that
development in that setting will affect
its rural character and consequently its
significance and then we'll just further
back or essentially just into the church
road to our left slightly behind us
looking across the site there so again
you can just see we're essentially at
the top of that area and again now we're
looking at the application sites so the
recommendation is to retain those four
reasons refusal that we had on the
previous application that we is
currently it appeal for those four
grounds so just to quickly run through
those again because it's outside the
settlement boundary it's contrary to the
application of the stay market area
action plan it doesn't comply with the
requirements of the MPP F in terms of
sustainable development having
particularly regards to the natural
historic environment we're going to lose
it as a site of open countryside forming
part of and contribution to the
significance of the great one listed
church it would be in positioned built
developments the country signed country
to cs5 and it would fail to demonstrate
that it wouldn't harm Coombs word Site
of Special Scientific Interest and
that's really that's the recommendations
refusal on those four reasons thank you
very much and we this point have enough
leaves you asked questions for clarity
yes
councillor Madison thank you and yeah I
was slightly concerned I couldn't find
in the papers anywhere a view from our
landscape consultant place services on
on this application I'm sure they had
things to say previously but this is a
new application yeah I think that's
because of the appeal situation that
we've got a specialist landscape
consultant who's had that discussion
with me I don't think they actually
provided us formal comments but agreed
that where we said previously was their
position they would be take for taking
and that's the position their diff
yes so we are defending the exact same
reason for refusal on the previous
scheme as proposed for this scheme at
Appeal thank you can I just ask about
the previous application which is
currently appeal for 160 dwellings I
believe can you just clarify if those
160 dwellings were actually going to be
over what is on the green open space on
our plan or whether they were crammed in
and it was a higher density the they
were coming further towards the village
of Coons so there is a degree of
reduction in the imposition into the
country signs whoever we still feel that
that projection would still have that
impact towards the countryside the
joining together with combs the impact
that would have and the overall impact
on the landscape so yes it is slightly
different but not significant we fail to
change that reason any other questions
at this point no okay so we will move on
okay so at the moment we have the
opportunity for the town council to
speak and we have Nick gali speaking
first on behalf of state market town
council just to be clear
cause this borders to villages we were
allowing both villages to have appeared
speak or both town and village and cooms
will be next so that both gets an
opportunity Thank You mr. chairman for
affording me the opportunity to speak
today on behalf of Sir market and
council stone market has grown
significantly in recent years with large
areas of new residential development the
Town Council has a record of supporting
rather than opposing such proposals as
it recognizes the need to provide
additional housing within the area
occasionally however an application is
submitted that the town council really
cannot support and once such as this
application in presenting the town
councillors objection we would ask you
to consider the following points there
is strong and justified local opposition
to the proposals and we wish to endorse
in particular the well recent
observations made by our neighbors the
Coombs Parish Council
we also endorse the views expressed by
historic England and Suffolk
Preservation Society in objecting to the
application on the grounds that the
proposed new housing would have a
harmful impact on historic rural setting
a grade 1 listed st. Mary's Church and
the characterful landscape in which it
is situated paragraph 1 line 3 of the
MPP F means the grade one listing of
this heritage as it means and I quote
great weight should be given to their
heritage assets conservation the Town
Council believes that the size and scale
of the proposed development of growth is
overwhelming when considered within the
context the local road infrastructure
indeed the town council feels that the
proposed Transport assessment and the
new travel plan reflect a lack of local
knowledge and appreciation of the
constraints that exist the cumulative
effects the existing bottleneck and
popular here on the edge come Campari's
Road development and this proposal for
138 additional owners will have a
detrimental effect upon the area and
would lead to acute problems with
traffic flow for which there is no
obvious solution the proposed primary
access to the site is less than that
ideal on poplar Hill and the extent of
the development
beyond that and visited by the stone
market area action plan the proposed
urban style development proposal
provides little opportunity for a rural
transition before reaching Coombs
Village the proposals fail to conserve
and enhance the natural environment or
recognizing intrinsic character and
value of the countryside
therefore endorse the comments made by
Suffolk Wildlife Trusts highlighting the
application site is located within
approximately 500 metres of whom's wood
site which is one of Special Scientific
Interest the wood being a Suffolk
Wildlife Trust Reserve and that the
proposals could have a harmful effect on
the wood because of its hillside
location this development would be
highly visible and have a detrimental
impact on the rural character of the
landscape paragraph 170 the MPP F
requires that planning policies should
contribute to and enhance natural and
local environment
finally the tank has objects the
provision of a small pocket play area
which in its experience adds little in
terms of play value for the local
community as evidenced by the many
underused play facilities that exist
across cedis Park it believes the
developer I'm sure sorry but the times
also could the last sentence yeah I am
he believes the developer contributions
should be allocated to more valuable and
sustainable community facilities than
the one proposed thank you thank you
very much do we have any questions for
Tamaki town count so at this point can i
I have a question have you had any
engagement with Gladman have they been
to the town council to explain their
application thank you thank you very
much
and next I'd like to invite Tony Bamber
up from Coombs parish council and again
three minutes please
mr. chairman Thank You counselors whose
pouch council would like to make four
points number one the traffic generated
by the proposed development in addition
to that from the hundred or more houses
yet to be occupied in the Edgecomb park
development will be severe and would
probably bring the traffic flow through
the poplar Hill bottleneck to cross its
point this alonein we think justifies
refusal on the transport grounds in NPP
F paragraph 32 to be clear the
bottleneck is not at the point where
this proposed development meets the road
but further towards Coombs forward where
the traffic has to negotiate all the
path cars point to the proposed
development would reduce the open
countryside separation between Coombs
and stone market to unsustainable
proportions contrary to the stone market
area action plan graph 6.46 point 50 and
6.51 and policies six point twenty and
six point twenty two it also fails to
recognize the intrinsic character of the
countryside
contrary to NPP F paragraph 17 and fails
to conserve or enhance the local
character of this part of the district
contrary to policy FC 1.1 of the adopted
core strategy focused review point three
the County landscape planning officer
commenting on the Edgecumbe Park
planning application reference 1492
stroke 15 described the site as being
quote in an elevated and visually
prominent location unquote that same
letter acknowledged that the layout
proposed in that application quote has
responded to this by using this area for
public open space and not for housing
unquote this present proposal would
negate all that careful consideration
and destroy a much loved and valued
landscape contrary to NPP F paragraph
109 the fourth point the impact on the
setting of summaries Church a great one
listed building would be substantial
eroding the visual value of what has
been described as probably the most
important Church in all East Anglia we
therefore urge the council to
this application thank you thank you
very much I just like to ask you the
same question have you had any
correspondence or have they been to
visit you with their plans the applicant
little no thank you any other questions
from members no thank you very much next
up we have an objector who would like to
speak and again you have up to three
minutes
it's Desiree Shelley if you'd like to
come forward to the same mic please and
when you're ready thank you my name is
Desiree Shelley and I'm speaking on
behalf of the save mill mount field
network opposition to this development
has swelled our second petition was
signed by more than 1,600 people in snow
market cows Ford Coombs little fembra
batter's furred emotes Tye demonstrating
the wide impact this application has on
our community you will have seen that
our petition and the 310 objections sent
to the council raised valid concerns
about Road Traffic and Safety and
overstretched health care services and
schools today my focus is on three other
key issues the impact on us at Mary's
Church the landscape and the separation
distance we believe that Mill mount
field is an important piece of a
countryside jigsaw without which we lose
much more than an agricultural field it
forms a vital part of the setting of
grade 1 listed at Mary's Church if
developed the only remaining
unobstructed view of our Church in its
historic rural setting with ancient
Coombs would as a backdrop would be lost
forever a narrow sight line through a
housing estate is no substitute Sint
Mary's is historically one of the most
important churches in East Anglia it is
also close to our hearts as a place
where we MA
rites of passage and bury our loved ones
the field enables people leaving Stowe
Market on foot or by car to enjoy an
uplifting panoramic view of clay hills
and a glacial Valley this cherished
Vista Stowe markets only seen at Gateway
would be almost completely blocked the
field is surrounded by a network of
public footpaths and quiet lanes that
link Clues fought and coos village with
some Mary's Coombs wood Church meadow
Nature Reserve and destinations further
afield these much-loved walks offer
attractive countryside views and
sightings of flora and fauna this
development would be a prominent
intrusion into rural countryside and
much diminish these views and the sense
of peace and tranquility which is good
for body and mind
Belmont field forms the major part of
the separation distance between Stowe
market and Coombs village it protects
their distinctly different identities
the physical gap would be radically
reduced and because of the valley the
visual gap as seen from both ends of
poplar Hill would be completely wiped
out the government consultation that led
to the current NPP f was called planning
for the right homes in the right places
Mill mount field is quite clearly the
wrong place and we ask you to reject
this application thank you that was to
the second three minutes so you must
have rehearsed it
thank you very much do we have any
questions at this point
No thank you very much okay so next up
we we could have a supporter but there's
none that wishes to speak and we could
have hear from the applicant or the
agent but they are not here today so we
now move to the ward members we have
councillor Keith scarf and councillor
Jared Brewster which the order in which
you go over to you Thank You mr.
chairman
yes I have read through the papers
relating to this application there was
really very little difference from the
application DC 18 zero to three eight
zero which was refused on the 26th of
September 2018 a reduction in house
numbers yes only really by a meager 22
this certainly doesn't mitigate any harm
to the setting of the grade 1 heritage
asset of Coombs church nor does it
prevent further isolation of the church
from the main residential area of the
parish whose name it serves this
development of 138 houses if approved
would reduce the separation buffer
between Koons and ster market which
Coombs Parish Council still market Town
Council as well as the still market area
action plan policies look to preserve I
note the historic England paper page 58
speaks of the even reduced number of 138
modern housing development site
retracting from the church setting it
goes on to explain the reason for the
grade 1 listing as being of an
exceptional level of special
architectural and historic interest the
whole paragraph really needs to be read
in order to fully understand the merits
of the historic building which needs to
remain in its current undisturbed
setting as seen from the village of
Coombs and indeed as Coombs can be seen
from the church Pera 310 of the report
states that the proposal is situated
within close proximity to the Coombs
Wood SSI and the grade 1 listed church
of sant Mary the proposal would resolve
in less than substantial harm to the
heritage asset not outweighed by public
benefits such that the proposal would
result in harm to the environmental
objective of sustainable development my
personal view is the application site
landscape provides the setting for the
historic for the history of the church
and also the breathing space between the
two communities
Pera three then goes on to speak about
the SSI which I will now turn to Coombs
Wood is a potato
botanically rich wood which has roots
stretching back to the Doomsday Book not
literally I think that in itself surely
accounts for its reason for being
designated an SSI it is a delightful
area to walk through but also needs a
level of protection to save God it's
wonderful environment and the flora and
fauna that can be found there many of
which are quite rare the applicant
speaks of other foot cards in the
vicinity which people would walk on with
their dogs however of course he has no
control on where people will walk and be
frank
Coombs would if I still had a dog to
walk and didn't realize the implication
of the SSI would be my choice in the
last application the applicant had
seriously underestimated the number of
dogs that would be walked by their
owners in this area this was fully
corrected by Suffolk Wildlife Trust the
additional risk that this development
would bring to Coombs would and its
biodiversity is just too great and the
area must be protected I realized that
Suffolk highways remain fairly relaxed
about the highway infrastructure that
would serve this site if it were to be
approved
however the concerns raised to hold some
weight
poplar Hill itself is a busy road which
has traffic calming measures and also
generally a number of Park cars are
parked in various spaces as has been
mentioned certainly to the lower end in
in the kumis Ward area I understand
these are also recognized as traffic
calming measures question that these
measures are the reason the considerable
traffic uses two other roads as
technically a rat run hillside is a
1930s Road which at most times has cars
parked on one side of the road and
appear for the majority of the time to
remain there all day and even worse in
the evening although some widening was
carried out a number of years back
it remains basically a single carriage
road and don't just don't go there when
the waste is being collected the NOI
Road leaving two Edgecomb Road the
latter being a circum it's 1960 Road
again it's not a great width and
congested much of the time with parked
cars often difficult to negotiate these
highway concerns are real not made up
given that farriers road will soon also
be connecting to poplar Hill almost
opposite to the proposed highway
connection from this application sight
will only create greater problems to
these highway issues whether those
issues are considered substantial is of
course in the hands of the county from
my cabinet position of economic growth I
would normally all things being equal
with the right homes in the right places
etc be supportive of an application
however these are the wrong homes in the
wrong places so I have no hesitation in
going to continue to what I'm say
members I fully support the views of
stomacher town council and of Coombes
parish council as well as the
representative of mill mound field to an
even greater state extent I would like
to thank Gemma for her report her
presentation and her recommendation and
I ask you members after your considered
opinion of what is before you to refuse
this application as per the officers
recommendation thank you mr. chairman
thank you very much if we have the other
councillor speaker then we can have
questions of the councillors at the end
thank you chair as joint wore caps now I
owe to the committee to reject this
application in the National Planning
policy framework there are 3 key
dimensions or objectives regarding
sustainable development economic social
and environmental amongst the many
reasons for refusal as we've heard one
the setting of the great one listed at
Mary's Church if granted this
application will result in harm to this
historic heritage asset and it would
completely alter the setting of this
church the close proximity to Coombs
would SSI the
those risks harm to this unique and
treasured area the proposal results in
an intrusion into the countryside and
would close the gap between the
settlements of the town of Stowe market
and the village of Coombs two entirely
different settlements this is in direct
conflict with mid-south occurs core
strategy and the stone market area
action plan the proposal falls in the
countryside and therefore conflicts with
the core strategy CS 1 & 2 overall the
proposal is our odds with the national
planning policy framework and would if
granted approval cause adverse effect
this would significantly and
demonstrably outweigh any benefits
regarding housing delivery and this is
unacceptable
the proposal is not sustainable
development under the environment and
objective of the national planning
policy framework thank you thank you
very much do we have any questions for
the ward members at this point yes kasa
Massey there has on these the traffic
points that have been made by various
people nobody's actually talked about
the Coombs ford junction only about
poplar Hill and whether you've got a
word or two to save one of you or other
of you about the that part of the
bottleneck yes thank you catch the
Matheson yes it is it is the bottleneck
at that end of town there is no doubt
all of the traffic flows through that
triangle any increased traffic at peak
times would result I think in a very
negative impact on the traffic in that
area and also for residents it is
already very widely congested at peak
times and I would suggest that this
development in conjunction with the
other development of Ferris Road will
only exacerbate the situation thank you
any other questions okay so members
we've had all the information put the
force for us now to debate and come to a
conclusion who wants to go first yes can
similar having listened to all the
arguments put for today both by the
Planning
so and by the representative stone
market Town Council Coons Parish Council
and our colleagues from the district
council personally I totally agree with
what you say and I will vote for refusal
of this application how's the man sir
Thank You chair
I do remember the previous application
coming to committee I believe I was on
that committee and I completely
supported the reasons for refusal and I
personally feel that nothing
particularly has changed yes they've
reduced the number and there's a
slightly more open bit of landscape on
the southern side of the development but
I still think that this is far too going
to cause far too much harm to the
setting of the listed building
notwithstanding the other reasons for
refusal so I thought catson well it was
going to propose something then but he
hasn't so I'm going to propose that we
go along with the officer recommendation
for refusal councillor filled my view is
where we're basically asking ourselves
to haarlem's 438 families out ye the
harms that he's expressed by so many of
the consultants a unanimous expression
that this should not go ahead and I
thought the parish council was
particularly clear in its views has been
mentioned by some of the other speakers
it seems to be totally clear to me that
the answer to my question is now that
the benefit doesn't outweigh the harm
and the harms to the listed building and
also things like the separation between
the village and the town and the the
traffic issues I often feel those are
exaggerated but in this case it seemed
pretty clear that they're not so I'm
quite happy to second the proposal
to refuse Thank You counsel thank you
yes I just thought we thought we'd go to
a vote I think we should just just throw
a particular emphasis back to the Sun
market area action plan and the in in
that document it was set out that the at
this end of town the the farias road
development which is going ahead
contains a very large element of of
bungalows and another housing which
would not attract additional peak hour
traffic and and I think this this
application for general purpose housing
flies so strongly in the face of that
that that although the County highways
seem to have forgotten what they said
ten years ago about the market in the
sub market area action plan that
argument still holds good Thank You
anyone else wish to speak I mean I I
agree I also will be voting the same way
I mean from me there are few key things
the lands outside the settlement
boundary and absolutely the stay market
area action plan is very clear was
expected so that's a very simple one for
me again the s the the SSI of Coombes
would and the impact on that I think is
particularly significant we are trying
to protect our environment and we need
to recognize the importance of an S SSI
then it was one too many S's and that
but SSI and also clearly the local plans
very clear and the impact on the great
one mr. Joe so to me it all stacks up as
to why we should refuse and you know on
a personal note I think it's extremely
disappointing and I said this last time
that an applicant who's putting in for
this sort of housing has not had any
sort of meeting with the parishes that
are involved but it's in their vicinity
all with residents that's really what we
would expect in mid Suffolk we expect
engagement between developers and the
residents and and
the town and parish councils and I think
it's really disappointing the Gladman
have chosen not to even show up today to
have the courtesy to discuss the
application with us I think is also
wrong and so I certainly will be voting
against this as well
would anyone else like to speak before
we go to a vote okay so it's been
proposed by council amount saw and
seconded by Councillor field that we
accept and follow the recommendation as
laid out in the papers on page 37 for
refusal all those in favour of refusal
place that's unanimous thank you very
much if you are leaving if I could ask
you to leave
fairly promptly because we've got lots
of other items on the agenda we're going
to move straight on to item number two
which is the land of East oli present in
Elms were DC 1804 to six seven
okay Thank You chairman this is item
number seven be in the papers
application reference DC 1804 to six
seven land east of Ollie Crescent in
Elms well the application is for
approval of reserved matters relating to
layout scale appearance and landscaping
in connection with outline planning
permission up to sixty dwellings granted
in May 2017 reference thirty four 69
forward slash sixteen for which the
decision notice has been included in the
lake papers for your for your reference
so full list of that decision including
all the conditions so I hope that's
helpful and also in the interest of
clarity for everybody what members are
being asked to consider today is purely
the layout landscaping of the site and
the design of the proposed buildings and
the principle of up to sixty dwellings
on the site and the means of access
there to through the existing estate
have always already been agreed as part
of the outline Planning Commission the
there is therefore no opportunity to
revisit issues of principle and access
today so just for clarification thank
you
the application has returned to to
committee after being deferred I
committee be on the 27th of March of
this year for officers to seek
amendments in terms of highways
revisions we visit as space standards
particularly with the affordable
dwellings and the seek a wider mix of
housing in particular more bungalows was
suggested by committee last time
so onto the presentation and the
location of Elms well just for
everybody's reference and the location
of the site within the village and if we
can see that it's that okay so the site
is here absolutely in the village north
of the railway line there this is an
aerial map and closer in there
the site location plan and the
constraints map the main constraints
being the network of one here and then
over the bridge there is another public
right-of-way trends adjacent to the rear
of the existing dwellings and to the to
the west of the proposal cycle this is
the the latest proposed site layout this
is revision M so that gives you a bit of
an idea of how many revisions within two
been through to get to this point and
just comparison for you with revision G
which was considered by committee last
time and some of the revisions the
access point here has changed from a
sharp left-hand Bend to more of a
t-junction effect as per the
recommendation of highways parking
and particularly in this location has
been moved in front of the affordable
terrace there that was prompted by
concerns that people would like to park
in front of their dwellings and there'd
be more on street parking so that has
been changed and two bungalows two
additional bungalows have been included
here at once
32 and 33 giving a total of six
bungalows now on the site instead of
four previously and some of us lights
revisions plots being moved away from
the corners of the highways to give more
more visibility and revisions to the
road layout as you can see there and
this has width as you'll see in the
recommendation received the support of
County highways and it's just a closeup
of the layer as proposed that is the
North section in the South section this
is where the affordable Wellings will be
so we have eight flats eight one and
two-bedroom flats two terraces one and
sorry of two and three-bedroom
properties and a pair of semi-detached
bungalows two-bedroom
some street scene elevations for you and
[Music]
isometric drawings of what the estate
may look like it's constructed few of
those these are the flats to the south
of the site then the larger properties
to the north to the individual
elevations and floor plans these are of
the four types of garages proposed
throughout the estate the proposed flat
building will have eight flats within
this single building one and two-bedroom
there
it's is the first terrace of affordable
dwellings this will be two or two and
three-bedroom properties and the second
affordable Terrace again two and
three-bedroom the bungalow semi-detached
which will be affordable properties
two-bedroom and the similar proposal for
for market purposes and the varying
designs plots 24 25 26 and 45 27 3 to 31
it's a three-bedroom sorry 2-bedroom
Terrace that will be market use and
these are the additional detached
bungalows proposed two of those plots 32
and 33 and that's plots 33 3 34 2 3 2 36
37 38 39
fortitude 14 41 and 42 and I was up
there 43 44 46 47 57 58 59 and 60 three
bedrooms then we detached and plots 48
49 48 being handed and plots 53 52 those
so the terrace at the top of these sites
plots 53 356 three-bedroom terrace under
some landscape drawings for you and the
the green areas indicates existing
planting to be retained and along the
existing current open edge there's new
native species hedgerow proposed
interspersed with some new tree planting
and existing yeah-yeah existing retained
it along the north as I've said going
through the site and to the south to the
railway edge this shows where the refuse
and recycle bins are proposed for
presentation and each dwelling has
access to the rear gardens so those can
be taken off the streets when they're
not required to be presented they're
outlined in yellow there for you the
presentation points would be
this is for references the plan which
the indicative plan which was approved
will considered as part of the outline
permission and just comparing that to
the current proposed one in front of you
now on to some photographs this is the
access to the site or a continuation of
the estate Road through three Bulli
present this is along the the north
boundary of the site we're looking
towards the existing recreational area
and village hall and then just turning
left from that previous slide you'll see
the existing dwellings fronting public
crescents excuse me
and further onto the left there
and this is the existing existing East
boundary of the site I'm just turning
left from that previous slide and
looking looking back north from that
point this is looking across the site
towards the point of access from Bali
Crescent just zooming in on that one and
this is the bottom far south southeast
corner of the site and looking left
along the railway line from that
previous slide this is taking a back
step
looking at the site from the wider
landscape and the site will start
roughly roughly here
and this finally is the thin finger that
you saw red which is the public footpath
connection to the to the main highway
which was secured as part of the section
106 under the outline so that will be
probably surfaced sorry and updates
since the recommendation there are a few
items and the the table papers including
the decision notice for the outline
Commission
but as per your papers officer
recommendation is for approval thank you
thank you very much can I just ask
questions so just some absolutely clear
obviously the planning permissions being
granted so that's given it's a matter of
looking at the the papers that the force
in terms of the layout and the design is
there anything that hasn't been changed
that the last committee when they sent
it away because they weren't happy with
it deferred it that hasn't been actioned
thank you Jay yes the one point which
perhaps hasn't been addressed was the
concern raised by members with regards
the space standards for affordable
housing
now those right live in in red in the
bundle and the comments received from
the strategic housing officers now we
have requested that those be be altered
but but the fact remains that we don't
have a policy to to back that up so it
is a little bit difficult to insist on
that so that's the reason that it hasn't
been changed and all the other requests
from the committee be has had been
carried out yes regarding highways and
they've increased the number of
bungalows so thank you any other
questions just councillor feels the
point
firstly I found that if I looked at page
1 1 7 and the landscape place services
it says for public open space provision
is neither adequate nor located
appropriately if I turn to page 1 to 2
in power 4 7 in the middle it says
members now have create a spacious and
cul-de-sac base layout with access to
public green space the countryside and
village services there seems to be a
conflict
yeah that's carried on through similar
comments in the reports on unclear
whether we're saying it's unacceptable
public housing space or that it's a
wonderfully spacious layout your views
on that the other issue I have when I
look at particularly side page 133 and
page 134 there are 2 different layouts
therefore the affordable houses and I
have a feeling you shoud another one on
the screen recently which one is it that
we're looking at get them answer those
points for the public open space because
of the existing provision to the north
of the site the fact that this site is
situated adjacent to open countryside
with good public footpath links it was
felt that the provision of the large
amount of public open space on the site
wasn't wasn't necessary as such because
of that existing provision in terms of
the affordable housing layout the one
that I've shown on the screen is the is
the correct one so we've had an updated
plan from the from the applicant so in
the current presentation that is the
correct one so the one that takes the
green vegetation and one puts car park
in places there is the correct one
so this is the correct plan and parking
now in front of the terrace that's
following highways comments in the
interest of avoiding on street parking
so that's the reason that's been changed
thank you any other questions yes sir
sorry cancer man sir thank you for
allowing me to speak
now I've just have a question about the
public footpath which runs from the
station or thereabouts the level
crossing up this side of the existing
development beside the railway and it
then makes sharp left-hand Bend and runs
along the western edge of this
development
could you please confirm that the
majority of the footpath which is
currently a field edge through the
development on the left on the right
hand and the right hand side is on the
western side of the development is now
going to mostly be on a pavement and on
the plan that you had up of the
affordable housing I could see no link
from the bit that runs along the railway
line to get to that particular bit of
pavement
you also had a photograph of that path
and said it would probably be surfaced
now remember when it went to outline
permission there was some talk about
upgrading that to a cycle route so could
you please comment on the footpath
improvements that are to be made with
this development yes the public footpath
surfacing
[Music]
there we go okay yes I think this shows
it best
now the existing public footpaths the
one running adjacent to the the east of
the existing development west of the
current proposal as proposed to be Hagen
surface as is the as is the finger I
suppose that landscape plan so that's
the that's the current proposal about
the link from the one from the station I
can't it doesn't look like there's any
part that looks like it turns up on a
tree bit of grass and where's the pass
well I don't have a plan of that but so
are you saying there is definitely a
path there's certainly a part and what
it's about is its surface rule it's
proposed to be surfaced under what we
had under the outline under the section
106 agreement okay it's under the
section 106 agreement it's already there
in the outline yes it's been Security
Council Matteson yes the the yeah are we
now getting the the brick walls that the
landscaping consultant is asked him for
this seems to be actually kind of a new
a new general standard that they're
coming up with boundaries that meet the
public realm should be brick walls
that's on page 1 1 7
this is the landscape drawing and don't
know if you can see it as proposed to be
fences or walls actually I don't know if
it shows it on their plan that
yeah brick walls in the most prominent
locations to the corners of the of the
roads any fences would be more set back
from the highway so anything that is
Julie prominent would be brick walls
that's what they're proposing okay so we
move on we don't have the parish council
here we don't have an objector we don't
have a supporter what we have the
applicant of agent Jeff Armstrong who'd
like to come forward and again like
previously you have up to three minutes
Thank You chair good morning everyone my
name is Jeff Armstrong and the planning
consultant working on behalf of Orbitz
homes following the deferral of the
application on in between 7th of March
we have worked closely with the our
offices as you've heard and the highway
authority and significant revisions have
been made to the proposals in order to
satisfy their concerns first in terms of
highways as has been explained to you
we've now provided a t-junction
at the site access a raised table and a
number of other amendments to the
internal rod geometry visibility and the
positioning and dimensions of the
parking spaces the highway authority
have confirmed that the revised leg
provides an acceptable arrangement which
accords with their standards and raised
no objection in terms of housing mix
we've provided two additional bungalows
to bring the total to six which is ten
percent of the site internal space
standards it's obviously been to explain
to you by your officer you don't have
any standards any policies to require
those stands at the moment that I can
confirm that the bulk of the properties
are just about in line with the
standards and some actually exceed the
standard so there's no issue that we are
trying to
produce something which is substandard
in terms of space going forward in terms
of amenity space the scheme has been
amended in order to provide an area of
private amenity space for the flats
which I think you've seen on the layout
plots form to AIDS in terms of boundary
and surface treatments the council's
landscape consultant has raised no
objection insofar as the proposal
relates to boundary landscape treatment
planting and the rights-of-way officer
has requested for all footpath routes
within the site to be surfaced in Hagen
which has been addressed on the
submitted plans and if you've heard from
your offices today I just want to pick
up a couple of points from early
discussion in terms of the open space
provision it was agreed at the outlying
stage that given the proximity of the
site to the opens open space provided
within walking distance of the sites
that there was no need to provide
anything on-site and that we should
focus the open space to the boundaries
of the site and in areas around the
flats which is what we've done the
public right of ways which again you've
discussed they will be upgraded and the
Hagen has been agreed and the upgrade
will be will be from the site to the
road to where the railway line is albeit
outside of the red line it is secured as
part of the 106 agreement and in terms
of the comment on the brick walls it is
our intention for boundaries on on the
common boundaries to be provided in the
form of brick walls not fences so I
don't think it's shown on those drawings
at the moment but it is shown on other
drawings which we have submitted the
revised game respect I would suggest
responds to all of the previous concerns
raised by members and the proposal has
no outstanding objections from statutory
consultative carefully considered the
revisions made since the application was
deferred and have written recommended to
be granted I therefore respectfully
request the members consider this
application favorably thank you thank
you very much do we have any questions
at all
yes council mess yeah they although I
was actually on the on the committee
that looked at this previously although
you've now added two more bungalows are
I think the number of bungalows is still
less
than the number that you discussed and
engaged with the parish council and so
that they are still not happy I was
wondering why you know why can we not
actually have the number of bungalows
that you originally envisaged and and
you know suggested will be the case to
the parish I think as I've explained to
to the parish because we've obviously
met them quite a few times during this
process and the original outline we've
had an indicative layout with an
indicative mix on the scheme has now
been passed on to orbit homes and
they've reviewed the site and from their
perspective the provision of six
bungalows along with the other mix of
two three and four-bedroom dwellings
provides a wide and varied mix which
meets anticipated and housing needs in
that particular area so we think 10% of
the site actually is a reasonable
provision for bungalows in that area
it's certainly the largest percentage
which any scheme has provided in turn in
percentage terms going forward in as
well so we haven't ducked the issue I
would say the 10% is a generous
provision thank you any other questions
councillor few just returned two foot by
somebody I'm looking at our report page
1 3 2 1 3 3 which are two halves of the
plan
am I correct in thinking that the brown
coloured foot wise are tarmac surfaced
or whatever is a short service and the
granny colored ones are hogging and if
so returning to the point of the link to
the group beside the railway the the
brown coloured surface appears to go
around the right-hand side going in of
the entrance and then it sort of
disappears under a load of trees there's
vague signs that there might be a foot
way under there but it's certainly not
colored at either gray or brown so what
is the intention in that area the grey
and brown within the main layout itself
would be
tarmacked all it is and up is an
architectural somewhat brown and Samar
are shown as gray but that because the
Hagen would be effectively running along
the existing link along that boundary
which we're discussing earlier and then
good we're gonna follow down the other
right-of-way to the railway station
so the Hagen would be there correct
[Applause]
you're gonna have to put your mic on
though it was on I said in the area
that's pretty tenuous to the to the
right of the plant where it disappears
under some trees what's the treatment
there sorry you're talking along this
boundary sorry to some I'm clearing your
yeah now that would be Hagen which would
run all the way through there as well
any other questions
yes cancer Turner just ask is there any
provision made for wildlife to get
through the brick walls such as
hedgehogs is anything to have been put
in place like petrol tunnels and things
it's just something that's gonna
probably be coming sort of because of
the you know our diversity like a
diversity problems and it's just
something said that wildlife trust we're
talking about I don't meet your
conference and it's something that
people don't think about but it might be
worth having I think yes question and we
weren't asked to provide any such
tunnels if we had if they appeared
Leanne asked we could have happy to have
a discussion with officers afterwards if
that's something which would assist I
guess it would be to do with whether we
have a policy on that that the planning
team would have to request yeah it's
something we can request by condition if
that's something members in mind to do
it becomes kind of one of our statutory
duties I think there's a specific policy
that particularly rates to hedge Agra
fencing but I think as a statutory duty
if members reminded that that's it and
they would like to do wicked out that
one it's a condition we're looking at
the landscape in part under the reserve
matters so I see no reason why you
couldn't do that make how much any other
questions no okay
so we'll move on thank you very much and
next we move we have two board members
counts the mounts or and counts that
geek councillor Mansoor
thank you now unfortunately I was unable
to be at the previous committee when
this reserved matters application was
determined back in March and I did raise
some issues there in what I sent for
that committee and I'm not convinced
that those issues have really been
addressed and similarly although this
new revised scheme seems to meet
statutory consort ease in terms of
highways the Parish Council are still
dissatisfied about the provision for the
public right-of-way and the bungalows
now I'm not going to deny that 10%
bungalows on this site is more than
other developments announced well but
when this development was first proposed
to outline stage it was not particularly
popular but residents fears were allayed
because the indicative plan showed a
large number of small dwellings and
bungalows and they thought well we do
need small dwellings and bungalows and
that's what unfortunately members of the
public look at indicative plans I think
that's what they're going to get so of
course when this reserved matters
application comes in and there's a
minimal number of bungalows they're not
quite so happy
so it wasn't particularly popular I am a
little disappointed in the provision for
the public right-of-way which is a very
popular public right-of-way I myself
have used it on a number of occasions
I'm not convinced that enough thought
has gone into where the path from the
railway line along the railway line
meets the existing path because I do
remember outline stage that was hoping
to become a cycle route so that people
could get to the center of a village
without going through the housing estate
and that they could then therefore use
their bikes it now appears to come
straight into the development and
there's just a patch of Hagen and a bit
of grass and there's a car park so no
doubt cyclists will just bounce over the
grass off the curb into the carpark I
don't think it's a particularly
wonderful
design I'm also a little bit confused
about the fact we're going to have a
hugging strip next to a tarmac footpath
and and it is very much an urbanization
of that particular footpath and I know
that the parish council has made a
suggestion that perhaps the footpath be
moved to the eastern boundary of this
development so it maintains its sort of
semi rural nature and runs along the
back of the housing because it now the
Hagen path adjacent tarmac seems a
little bit bizarre to me and I'm also
disappointed that the comments from the
strategic housing about the minimum
space standards now whilst we may not
have a policy about that we should be
looking forwards and and if if the
reformed Wellings do not meet are not
big enough perhaps this isn't the best
of designs and although the layout has
been agreed by Suffolk County Council
highways I find it a bit odd that
there's a little loop in there for
people to race around but there you go
that's just my opinion the only other
thing I have to comment on is in the
report page one well aides it says
there's a travel plan response which is
part of Suffolk County Council's
highways response which I haven't
managed to see anywhere so I don't know
whether there are any comments about the
trouble plan so I I don't
I personally don't think that this
so-called improved design and layout is
has gone far enough
from the previous time it came to
committee so I am NOT in support of this
application thank you any questions for
the ward member and I haven't had an
email or any correspondence from
councillor geek so there's nothing for
me to read out on that so members that's
it we've had all the information put
before us it's over us to discuss debate
and to come to a conclusion
but kalsa having him say something to no
one else - no - I - I'm concerned about
the size of the housing but but like you
know we said there's nothing really we
could do about it and so I'm it's
disappointing but you know if there's
nothing we can do there's nothing we can
do
having listened to everything personally
I agree what came to having him says but
I'm actually in favor of this particular
application so I would actually move to
agree with the Planning Officers
conclusion for approval that's rich
thank you I'm just off the back of what
and councillor Mansell was saying can I
just ask the officers would it be
possible to attach a condition about the
potential moving of the footpath to the
eastern boundary of the dwelling to make
it more sort of sustainable and
continuing it's sort of rural setting I
mean there are conditions in the outline
about how they dealt with I think moving
it wholesale becomes a public
right-of-way issue in itself I don't
think they've objected to what we're
looking at is that right yeah public
rights-of-way been consulted no
objection there have been a few
revisions giving it a bit more space I
think you is required to have two metres
they seem happy with the hogging surface
proposed just a point to note they are
proposing another footpath along the
along the open boundary now it won't be
a formal public right-of-way but it at
least gives the opportunity for members
of the public to walk along that
boundary which they do in informally at
the moment
as I've seen when I was on site anyway
so it is a very big undertaking to move
the public right-of-way as well and if I
understand if there's just one objection
then it needs to go to the Secretary of
State so it's you know potentially a big
issue and there's a lot of cost in that
financial so I think really what you're
saying is not impossible but very
challenging it would be a big
undertaking for the developer and the
County Council I would suggest as much
so probably a bit outside our remit
ready okay counselor field okay I'd like
to dispute that but having some
committee I guarantee I'm not convinced
it's that difficult to move but there
you go
I don't really know what to say about
this one in a way I've looked at the
indicative layouts and the current
layout I hope to sell not particularly
convinced we're moving forward maybe in
some places and perhaps backwards in
other places when has the fear that if
we send it back again which direction
would we progress you know there are
comments now the one that was made if we
seem to have built a mini racetrack
around the middle of the development but
we've unquestionably improved the the
junction with the existing routes and
that was something that concerned the
committee greatly the last one I'm sure
I was on that as well and that is
clearly better I'm somewhat concerned
that there seem to be umpteen layouts of
what we do with the affordable housing
around but we do have one that perhaps
is the favorite one
it does seem decidedly odd look we've
got a foot wide a Holguin foot way with
a with a footpath next to it seems to be
taking spice up for the fun of it so I
have to say that having decided to tell
you something I really don't quite
school where I finish out
supporting this in that it it has have
an improved number of bungalows which
local people appear to want that we have
made some improvement to the road
structure that we don't want to this
carry on forever wandering aimlessly
around on the designer space so I
suppose I'll have a bit of a presumption
that I will support this but that's all
I'm prepared to say at the moment
customers yeah it is it is still
disappointing say not only in regard to
the bungalows not only that of the
number of thought it was but I think in
in terms of those affordable than layout
the you know the reason there is this
general recommendation that's that
social housing should be pepper potted
and this signal II does not do that and
you know alas it sticks all of the
affordable housing up against the
railway line and you know I'm not happy
I'm not happy at that approach but also
I look I look in vain in the conditions
for some really good acoustic noise
protection fraught for the social
housing from the railway which will only
increase in its number of trains going
past work is in hand on that apparently
so not not very not very happy I think
you know one or two other things that
councillor Mansell's added in as well it
doesn't really you know it's it's better
than it was but really it should be
better than this no one else wants to
speak I mean my viewers I will be
supporting this the recommendation of
officers it came to the previous
committee the previous committee sent us
a way to look at
making a number of changes and we've
heard from the officers that all the
changes that were recommended have been
made so and I think actually we need to
recognize that having 10% bunglers is a
positive thing the parking was very was
located before where the railway track
was and the previous committee asked him
to move it in front of the affordable
housing so that the people could go from
their cars straight into the affordable
housing so on one hand with they're
coming to the committee with the car
parking up against the railway line then
it's moved so we can't I don't think we
can criticize them for doing that and
then it moved and then too for it to go
back that's what the committee before
asked them to do the suffer I think the
crucial bit for me as well as the
junction the coming in at that
t-junction clearly there that's been
listened to they've listened to the
request and they've made the changes I
accept of course there could always be
more and more improvements but I think
also we need to recognize that the
developer has sat down with our team has
looked at what's been requested has
tried to make as much as many changes
possible to bring the site forward and
so I will be supporting the
recommendation yeah
councillor having them yes sir I'd like
to second I'm cancelling realism
recommendation that we am what perhaps
with some mitigation the noise from the
railway line you know over this the
affordable housing we just touched on
the acoustic barrier because you do see
acoustic barriers in the fence way and
things like that or how would that work
and and how would that be conditioned if
that was the wish of members well refer
your attention to the outline plank
permission
there is a acoustic and noise condition
already on the approval which we're
we're looking at that is in hand that
we're in discussions with Environmental
Protection and so what was saying is
that's already covered in the tree in
the app yes yes but not fencing
I think it's covered the acoustics are
covered in the outline okay anyone else
wish to speak before we get to a vase
yeah councilman yeah i accepting that
that the the acoustic issue is dealt
with on this sufficiently girl with or
not so sure but it is it is it has been
done I suppose the other thing that we
looking for the the proposes to accept
would would indeed be the the hedgehog
gaps in in the boundaries in lots of
places
the proposal ii are happy that we have a
condition in there that it's appropriate
I thought no objection to that thank you
yeah okay so can we add an appropriate
hedgehog friendly entrance and exits I
think is what we're looking for okay so
on that basis I think we'll go to voters
no one else wishes to speak all those in
favor of the recommendation as laid out
in the papers on page 124 with the
additional hedgehog access all those in
favor of the recommendation please
as unanimous thank you very much okay
we're going to take a quick five-minute
break and start again at five past
eleven please on the next item
you
hey so welcome back everyone
we now move on to the next item on the
agenda which is DC 19 SS Rio one land
north of East of Florin Road in Crete
inocent Mary and thank you chair this
application before members is a full
application for a mixed-use development
of three detached dwellings and
associated garages and 6b1 industrial
units and 1 beta industrial unit on the
site in the parish of creating simple
Airy the plan you see on the screen
there just to give you some orientation
of where roughly where that is it's red
the red dot this show this plan with the
yellow arrow shows the location of the
site and you'll also note the location
of Needham market to the west and part
of creating some Mary settlement to the
north you'll also see the red line which
is the a14 trunk road this is a larger
scale map which again shows Cretans and
Marian need a market and the area of the
application is where the red dot is
there the other useful thing that you
can note here is where the B 1078 joins
the a14 trunk road this is an aerial
shot of the site which also shows
adjacent land uses including residential
to the northwest immediately to the
northwest again the trunk road and a lot
of agricultural development or a
cultural land on the other side of the
road particularly this is a larger scale
aerial map which again shows the same
level of detail a site location plan
which is useful because it does indicate
where
the nearest dwellings are all clear or
perhaps than the aerial photograph this
constraints map indicates that ecology
or biodiversity has been found on the
site previously there's indication of
protected species have been found
previously which is indicated by the the
triangular point there this further
constraints map shows the land use of
classification for agriculture and
you'll see the majority of the site is
green which is great 3 a smaller area
force of in a grade 2 category this is
the application site and the layout that
you're being asked to consider today in
effect it can be divided as I've said in
the report into two areas you've got the
residential development which is the
three houses along the road here served
offer a point of access with their
associated gardens and then immediately
to the side and the rear of those is an
area of proposed new planting and that
would lead sorry you've got a second
access at this point here which would
lead to the proposed b2 unit the general
industrial unit and the six b1 units the
other thing you'll note from that
particular plan is the parking
allocation for the industrial units
this is a plan of the proposed dwelling
on plot one you'll see as I said in the
report it follows a vernacular approach
a traditional formed dwelling one and a
half stories in effect a Chalet
constructed of brick and tile with
dormers in the roof similar approach
taken for the central dwelling and the
one at the other end plot three again
the outbuildings garroting that would
serve to the dwellings follows that
simple vernacular approach in terms of
design this is the proposed plan and
elevations of the b1 units you will
notice follows more contemporary design
which of mono pitch roof metal clamp
balls and a metal roof there is also a
brick lead detail the thing I'd like to
point out on this as of mentioned in the
report is as well as the three units
here you've got three larger units these
ones which also include a level of MIT
saline storage towards the rear this is
the proposed b2 unit this is the unit
that the applicant wants to actually
construct and relocate his business to
again it follows the contemporary
approach the contemporary design is what
it is it's a large unit but it's broken
down incrementally into individual
elements to try and deal with the
overall volume so therefore you have a
two-story administration area here for
example which adds interest to the
overall appearance of the building this
is a floor plan again you won't see that
too much detail of how the bb2 unit
works and this is a first floor plan as
well
this is as I said in the report there's
a notable topography change across the
site from the end where you have the a12
sorry 814 down to floor damn road so
that's the section through the site with
the be one unit there and the
residential this is a section through
the site with the b2 unit ghosted which
again shows that the area which the b2
unit would sit on is higher than the
area that'd be one unit would sit on
slightly but that reflects the
topography of the site this plan shows
the required accesses to the site it's
part of an assessment that was submitted
with the planning application there's a
single point of access as I said to
serve the residential units a further
point of access to serve the commercial
unfortunately you can't quite see them
clearly enough but there are lines drawn
from the center of both of those
accesses which demonstrate that the
visibility's blaze can be achieved
across highway land which is a key
consideration
there's no third party land involved
this drawing here is reflecting of that
where it shows the area of green as
being the land within the highway so
moving back to the previous plan for
example the chord of the visibility's
play on the entrance to the commercial
element go straight down at this point
and that the forced comfortably through
green land that forms part of the
highway some quick photographs of the
site this is looking up flawed and rode
towards the the housing the existing
housing that's a long road existing fear
about this is the existing boundary
between the site and the adjacent
dwelling nearest dwelling this is
pointing the camera towards the trunk
road you can't see the trunk road
because of the rise but it does give
some idea of the difference in height
between the front and the back and again
the approximate location where the dot
is where the red sorry where the b2 unit
would go that does give idea an idea of
the topography rising topography towards
the red and this has been included to
show that there is existing hedging in
trees along the frontage which would be
impacted as part of the development
works so there would be proposals to
actually replace planting as appropriate
in order to achieve the required
disabilities play lastly I'd like to
show you a slide which officer can take
a photograph from the a4 things get too
dangerous but this is taken from Google
Earth which gives you an idea of the
height difference between the a14 and an
approximate position of where the site
Falls which is roughly where you see the
fencing location there the other thing I
should have mentioned that we're going
to mention is that we've had a late
representation since the application was
submitted which is in your so when after
the air formulation of the committee
report was in your table of papers which
deals specifically with the issue of the
traffic regulation order and you'll also
see there's a response in there
unfortunately we couldn't get Highway
Authority officer to attend this warning
but there is a response in writing from
the highway authority officer in
relation to the comments that are made
in that letter thank you so much do you
have any questions discounts are having
ham um thank you I'm practically the max
or anything show me where the nearest
other industrial or commercial buildings
are I don't think I have a map to
actually show you that
Oh
really is in need market yeah which is
there and then this ad site along that
road which is one away where the waste
treat the the mulch place which is the
other side of the village so there is
there's a Brahimi site on that road and
then in needham market there's a much
bigger industrial site then further
along there's a waste mulching place yes
councillor field don't answer Manson
just a couple of things one of them was
the the be to use whether there was any
indication of the sort of noise levels
and things from laddies an existing
business which is likely to be
translocating and noise is obvious in
issue you might argue right up against
the I fourteen but as you saw on a
picture that's it you know someone we're
cutting and to the best of my knowledge
have visited the area and am aware that
there's not a great deal and also he's
there likely to be much from the beto
use the other issue is is there any
restriction on the number of employees
who would occupy like that be to use the
Cal Poly needs there as we all know it
can be useless if you suddenly find
someone with a hundred employees who
wish used to occupy the into our local
Road network so there's two questions
there the other one I had really was
about the ancients at the last time I
seem to remember this coming forward
there was a lot of fuss about the
entrance and should it be configured to
encourage ice TVs and things to move in
one direction only ie towards the early
fall to him I didn't see anything about
that in this current plan so a couple of
questions no this this application has
been before us before hasn't there and
at that time there was a lot of fuss
about the the entrance and what you
could or couldn't do to ensure traffic
many immigrant interaction I think just
because it didn't come before us it was
withdrawn so we had the papers and it
was withdrawn before the meeting so
you've seen the papers but we've never
had a discussion or a presentation on it
before yes towards our councillor fields
questions we haven't got any details of
existing noise levels existing building
or the operation what we are suggesting
following the consultation response from
environmental control is that there
would be noise attenuation in this
particular development so there would be
controls over the new one I can't offer
you any information on the existing
there was I'm afraid I mean by inference
of be to general industrial use is
noisier than a b1 b1 as I've said in the
report is a use that can be located in a
residential area usually without causing
any too much too much nuisance but we
were comfortable on the basis of the
information we received from
environmental control that that could be
adequately conditioned to control that
properly there wouldn't be a restriction
on the number of employees that would be
Jett be able to be operated or sorry
employed there I think the the
application submission indicates that
there would be a gain of employment to
25 from the current 18 but I think in
terms of the economic benefit of it
which we've taken as part of the
balancing of this application we would
encourage the opportunity for more
employment obviously but the the issue
in relation to parking is that your your
parking
standard for commercial uses a maximum
standard anyway as opposed to a minimum
so we can't actually require a minimum
level of provision in relation to
commercial development whereas we can
with residential so we're comfortable
with the level of parking provision
that's been proposed on the site the
entrance issue is the case that the
entrance has been designed in order that
HGVs could could go both ways
there isn't a control that we could
require under planning to stop them
doing that so don't think we could
enforce it in all honesty it would be a
nun of unenforceable condition the only
way we can actually or the only way that
could be done I think would be is if the
access were designed specifically to
preclude white turns out of the site
which would affect not only HGV traffic
but would affect car traffic as well so
it has to be a case that all thing all
traffic was pointing down one way which
I think in terms of I mean I don't know
about the highway impacts of that but I
think that would be the only way that
you could successfully control I don't
think you could condition here or any
way yeah absolutely
I'm gonna say travel plans are quite
effective at least when the local member
then goes to Tim Passmore don't ask for
something to read on he has a leaver to
use and people probably do it by them to
a much greater extent than we believe
the other issue is to say is you do
indeed in in the recommendation say
control of noise emissions from
commercial units there's no indication
there of what sort of control you know
you could maximize it if I want to be
emphasize my point Dan Samantha thank
you I've got three points I would like
to ask questions on the first of which
is it's also to do with the entrance the
photographs that you took look like they
will have Jason to a current gateway
onto the from the road to the field is
that where the entrance to the
residential properties is to be or
rather going to close that one up and
make a new entrance that's my first
question the second question is about a
bit of mixed messaging we're getting in
our report on page 199 we have our
economic development officers comment
the demand for small scale industrial
premises outstrips current supply in the
district and we have a comment from one
of the representations that says
existing industrial estates in the area
struggle to find tenants so I'd like to
comment on as which which of those we
have evidence for and also on the
recommendation on page two one one
sometimes we're referring to industrial
units and sometimes we're referring to
commercial units a are they the same
thing and if they are can we be
consistent and calling the same thing in
the different conditions in particular
15th a 14th and 15th bullet point on
page 2 1 1 we have reduction of hours of
use of industrial units the control of
noise emissions from commercial units
are they one of the same things or not
yes we've regard to the first issue the
field gate that you could see in the
presentation pocket slide up that shows
that that is in the approximate position
of where the proposed access to the
residential element would be and which
is shown with the red dot here and it's
proposed to add a second access along
the road so the counselors right they'd
seen that that sort of location there I
can't say it's precisely in there baby
it's roughly where that position is the
availability in all honesty I've advised
I've relied on the advice that we've
received from the economic development
officer in relation to that I know that
we've had representations that tend to
suggest otherwise but I think that if
our economic development team are
advising me on the back of presumably
their own research then I think that
that's a satisfactory of you to put
forward to two members
commercial/industrial I'll take the
point there is a subtle difference
between commercial industrial in regard
to in this case b2u sees straightforward
industrial use commercial use can be
incorporated ruined beat one because it
can include things like research and
development businesses that are not open
to sorry offices that I'm not open to
the public things like that so there is
a subtle difference between the take the
point come back on that so so the
restriction on hours of use of the
industrial units doesn't cover the ones
at the back of the development I get a
bit month to what we want to be to our
time sorry I haven't got that in my head
yet but is there a restriction of hours
of use proposed as a condition for all
the commercial stroke industrial units
or only one part of them apologies for
the confusion that would be the case is
it badly worded I'm sorry
the condition is its all units yes thank
you
yet light cancer field I was quite
concerned particularly reading the
environmental health comment on page 199
and sort of struck by the fact that
we're not limiting this to this
particular use of this applicant and
then what they're doing at the moment
and as it says the b2 unit however can
be any general in dust industry so how
much can we how much can we rely on the
noise condition to
to restrict the sort of general industry
that might turn up at some future point
once we've got b2 permission given and I
have a second question I'll come back in
a moment perhaps the issue of control by
condition is one element the second
element would be restricting the use of
the b2 building to the occupier sorry
the the applicant at this time that
would avoid it's a suggested condition
will it point for on page 211 I think
what we are saying is that if you accept
to be to use what you would be accepting
is to be to use that's being applied for
now it was not a cart long to be to use
because that would need to be considered
as a separate element yes so I mean it
seems that he kind of feels a bit too
restrictive to say this is a b2 you
sport for whatever they're called
company that's supplying at the moment
but on the other hand if we did that
presumably all it means is that if some
future user comes along then they have
to come back to the planning department
and say you know can we vary this
condition is that is that where we would
be with that then yeah so I think what
we're suggesting with that condition is
it's that type of use that the applicant
is undertaking we're not limiting it to
the applicant specifically so another
company could come in and carry on the
same use but if somebody came and I want
to do something different they would
then have to apply for change of use and
which one obviously we would consider
that accordingly
yeah I think it doesn't quite come
across in that bullet point with that
sort of point four covers that point
yeah it's except second question quite
quite a different one really on much
more on the principles and that is
really whether officers can see any
adverse consequences if if this
application was implemented in part I
mean it's it's saying well we need the
houses in order to fund the the
investment in the commercial premises or
the industrial premises which it's a
little bit not quite where we usually go
in in combining things you know okay is
there any add you know if they decide to
build the houses are not the industrial
or vice versa is there any particular
concern that would arise from that it's
we've been asked to consider the
application that's being put forward but
the point is all of the app all the
elements of the land-use elements that
comprise this application are departure
so therefore we've had to consider both
elements as whether they're acceptable
as departures not combined but against
the general sorts of policy thrusts that
relate to each use so if one were to
take place in advance of the other and I
suspect that's unlikely from what what
the applicant is telling us because it's
quite clear that the residential
development is is there in order to fund
the building of the new business so I
think that it's it's implicit really
that one follows the other I'll take the
point if they want to implement the
application they could seek to implement
the commercial element first but as
we've considered the commercial element
as almost like a standalone piece
although it's part of a mixed-use
proposal overall I wouldn't feel you
know too unhappy about the commercial
Amann element by itself taking place on
that particular
yes I suppose what I'm you know what I'm
concerned about is that if we if we
justifying the houses there because
because they're going to fund that the
the employment you know there's nothing
to stop in the implementation being
carried out for the housing and then
take the money and go you know that's
what I'm just that we're not we're not
making I'm a bit worried that we're
making that judgment but it might be
unsuitable place to put houses unless
with getting the employment yeah I think
the justification of the housing is
based on the current situation with
regard to five-year housing land supply
MPP F and the the age of certain
policies in the local plan unfortunately
so there is a justification separately
for the residential development it's not
I don't want you to think that it's
being justified purely on the basis of
it being a an enabler for something else
to take place there's it's important on
a pattern I'm drawing it out clearly
enough but it is important to consider
each element of this against the current
policy and the MPP F and consider
whether there is an acceptable reason to
allow departure in this case yeah it was
just say so if they had come forward
with just the houses we would be looking
at recommending for approval we've had
various houses to accreting to Mary that
have been considered sustainable because
of the facilities the services the
access through to lead and market within
walking distance so I think in terms of
if we'd have the houses alone and we
didn't have the industrial that wouldn't
become an issue or a reason for refusal
and some rights if they justify for the
applicants the money for the industrial
it's a benefit from our point of view
but it doesn't mean that if we built the
houses and the industrial didn't come
forward that would necessarily be an
issue from planning the point of view
it's a benefit to the applicant and that
we can understand and if that delivers
jobs it becomes a benefit in that
respect if they were only to build the
commercial again would it cause high
or be unacceptable I think it's
sufficiently remote from the existing
houses we're not considering harms the
proposed houses again there's enough
justification for each part in its own
right does that help
Thank You councillor Manson sorry that
thank you for um for letting me come
back because I've just thought of
another question I'm sorry that's the
way my mind works things come to me
little bursts and now whilst I
appreciate that there are environmental
sustainability standards for industrial
units that I think are imposed we
haven't heard anything about them and I
just wondered if there were any
proposals for low carbon heating
sustainable water usage or the rest of
it for these industrial units and I'm
sorry if it is in the report I can't
find it anywhere but certainly it's
something that if in the planning
statement that accompanies a planning
application the applicants agent has
indicated that they're open to taking on
board and it's something that we would
seek to consider or seek to secure of
our condition on a planning permission I
can't say exactly what the scheme would
be or schemes would be at this stage
because we haven't the information in
front of us but it's something that we
can incorporate into a and approval if
you were minded to accept the decision I
think let's talk to the applicant when
they come up any other questions at this
point
no Mike Epps will move on so we don't
have anyone from the parish council we
have an object and mr. Richard board Lee
if you'd like to come up to the mic and
again if you have three minutes
and whenever you're ready if you just
push the silver button good morning my
name is Richard board Lee and I live in
their property next to the application
site and together with the residents of
flawed and Road my wife and I strongly
object to this planning application for
me reasons firstly the access and
immediate road infrastructure is in moyu
not fit for purpose the only thing I
unfortunately have to say to demonstrate
this is that in April this year a
teacher from Clayton high school was
killed at the junction of Lawton Road
and Cardinal Road only a few yards from
the proposed industrial entrance and is
this really a junction that this
committee wants to send more traffic and
more HTV through or have also seen three
other minor accidents at the same spot
this year more than two there's a row of
very mature silver birch trees along the
boundary between the application site
and our property two of which have not
been accounted for on any of the
pictures by either the applicant or the
council they are both on our land and
fifty four or five feet in height on the
junk on the boundary and the route
protection area appears to conflict
strongly with plot one this dwelling
should at the very least have been
situated further from the boundary which
will of course impact on the rest of the
residential units and they may all need
to be repositioned no residence in
floored and Road wished to see
industrial development some of which is
B to which once b2 is given even in a
restricted form as I've had suggested
that can easily be turned over to
anything so it could be something it it
could be heavy industry in no time at
all
also a and you know it's very unsuitable
for good vehicles line by an industrial
estate is very close has footpaths and a
main bus route this estate has neither
will the proposed estate and in summary
this is the wrong type of development
for the wrong location for which there
is no need
allowing delicate development to take
place here will result in a major
unacceptable change to the character and
appearance of the area wider countryside
and the landscape in general it will
also have an unacceptable impact on
highway safety as I've just
unfortunately had to point out thank you
thank you if you just one sec we may
have a question or two for you yep
counsel hiding him it's not really a
question I was just running a friendly
if you can show the picture with the
road where the fatality occurred on the
thing
thank you much any other questions thank
you very much
we now have a sport we have the agent
Ben Elvin and again you got to come up
and three minutes please
Thank You chair good morning members and
thank you for the opportunity to address
you this morning and firstly Frankie to
Mister hit pepper as well for his report
and presentation on the case the
applicant is pleased that the benefits
of the scheme have been recognized and
the positive recommendation is made as
you've heard the application proposes
two main elements comprising the total
of seven commercial units and three
residential dwellings as the committee
report identifies the economic
development team have recognized the
benefits the real economy resulting from
the proposed commercial development and
this includes a new building for the
applicants established business which
employs many people 19 currently and has
outgrown its current premises the
delivery of jobs and support for the
local economy our core aims of both the
MPP F and the council's own policies and
this proposals delivers both of those
benefits the scheme offers the
opportunity for six smaller business
units and the expansion of the
applicants business which will boost
employment further the applicant raises
no objections to the suggested
conditions which would ensure there is
no detriment to existing residents and
hopes these will be taken forward to
offer assurances to all this will not be
an operation that gives rise to any loss
of amenity particularly given the
background noise from the a14 which will
significantly outweigh any low level
noise resulting from the proposal
furthermore the proposal brings for
three new dwellings which would provide
an active buffer between the new
commercial buildings and the existing
dwellings to the west these dwellings
are well designed and would provide a
logical extension to the existing linear
of development generating an attractive
frontage to the site and making
appropriate use of this underused piece
of land they would contribute to the
housing land supply and enable the
delivery of the commercial buildings and
they are therefore an important part of
the proposal as you've seen the site is
well related to neither market and to
the a 14 and a 140 providing good access
to facilities and services and to the
highway network the scheme would also
deliver good quality new landscaping and
appropriate drainage as confirmed by the
relevant consul tees who is noted raised
no objections since there we've drawn
the previous application the applicant
has submitted further highway
information including speed surveys and
highway safety improvements the highways
officer is now satisfied with the
proposal and the new axes have been
designed in accordance with the highways
engineer's requirements the applicant
will extend a 30 mile an hour speed
limit which we understand the parish
council are also looking to take beyond
this point in any event
good visibility exists the accesses and
the proposal has been found safe and
suitable for all turning to some of the
local comments it is highlighted that
industrial units are out of keeping with
this area yet this is a road that
contains Brahimi's headquarters a number
of our commercial sites in the immediate
vicinity of Rohini and which sits
adjacent to the a14 in close to a 140 it
is precisely where such unit should be
the land is not agricultural in use and
hasn't been for at least 30 years
nothing currently grows here as you've
seen from the photos and the grass has
only required cutting once in the last
two years the new landscaping would be
properly better than to ensure that so
it benefits from a full and attractive
landscaping scheme it is in effect the
parcel of underused land that be more
efficiently used if the proposal
supported for those reasons is hope that
members will support this proposal
secure the delivery and security of
these jobs and delivery the housing and
please grant brain permission for the
sustainable development thank you thank
you very much I think we're gonna have
some questions probably on the same line
you just explained more about the
business that's going to operate within
the b2 what the more about that
absolutely the the business is located
on the edge of stone market currently in
an industrial estate but has outgrown
the premises and what they do is their
electrical contractors so and most of
their work is carried out on sites so
they have people that will come in the
morning and pick up their orders for the
day and travel out there are eight or
nine office staff currently and they do
manufacture within the unit but it is in
the electrical components so it is your
traditional soldering iron type approach
it's not heavy industrial in any way
shape or form and and currently it's
immediately adjacent to residential
properties where there hasn't been any
complaints previously in all the years
they've been there okay count some
answer thank you I've got a couple of
questions one relates to my previous
question about environmental
sustainability in terms of energy and
water usage because looking at these
diagrams it looks like the units at the
back of the site I've got a nice
south-facing sloping roof what might be
suitable for such things for solar
panels so I wonder if you could comment
on on the environmental sustainability
of energy and water usage and the other
question I've got
about the vegetation barrier between the
residential dwellings and the neighbor
has just commented on some of the trees
along there and and on the plan that we
have on our page 2 to 2 it does look
like the trees sort of stop where the
house is as if there's not going to be
any buffer so could you comment on both
of those items please yeah absolutely I
mean in terms of the renewable energy
generation that sort of things but my
client would happily accept a condition
requiring a full scheme to be providing
data we haven't developed a solar panel
scheme or anything of that nature in the
moment but he's more than happy to so if
we wanted water consumption levels those
sorts of things is by means of a
condition more than happy to accept that
Chairman and will put forward a full and
detailed scheme as part of a condition
that hopefully will you know meet the
sustainability officers requirements in
that way so and he's he's open to it I
think that and that's how we left it
with this omission we made is that we're
open to developing it we have we haven't
done so yet yeah in terms of the trees
as I understand the situation that the
neighbor has just brought forward the
trees on the boundary which are between
the existing property
Jasper Lodge in the end plot one in
essence I think you know from the point
of view of where the construction
elements of this would go again we could
probably do all this by condition in the
sense of looking at you know a no deck
construction or something of that nature
under the root protection zone supported
by an abort cultural impact assessment
of those trees as part of the
conditioner and we're more than happy to
do that again if that helps thank you
very much
any other questions yes yeah I I had a
look at the way the existing location
and I think you know you've given us the
usual phrases about well related to that
to the highway system etc the the
existing location is well related to the
dual carriageway section of the stone
marketer Needham Road I wondered whether
the applicant had explored the
possibility of actually building
additionally on at that site which say
has C it's an industrial site and
what better related to the highway
network I think from from memory and
I've only been to the existing site once
it's quite contained that that's fair
sage on the existing site even the car
parking is quite limited for where they
are at the moment and the sandwich van
also uses that space over the lunch hour
and takes up a couple of spaces as well
so because it serves a wider cluster and
rather than just John's own business I
think in that sense there's not as I'm
aware a space on his existing site to do
so this land is within his family and
has been fought for many many years and
given the opportunities to seek to
actually address what he needs in terms
of space rather than try and I don't
know cram something onto a site that
probably isn't capable of taking it the
opportunity here is much more practical
one Thank You counsel
two things you mentioned noise levels
from the I 14 I wondered if you have any
you've made any records of what sort of
levels they are because currently and
always a control condition is is sort of
meaningless it doesn't have any figures
on it noise is one issue second issued
and the numbers of employees you
mentioned a process where people come in
and collect their work for the die and
disappear off to remote locations these
that people within the whatever it was I
tuned nineteen at the moment and twenty
twenty something you mentioned they
included within that or nineteen extra
just sort of locally based office staff
with some substantial numbers of others
to create chaos in morning and evening
no no nineteen is the total totality of
the staff employed so that includes the
people that are going out on site so
there's office is primarily an office
base element in this building and some
construction and manufacturing with a
large number of people going off site
and actually fitting things and fixing
things out on the on the ground but the
nineteen includes all of that John's
proposal or the captain's proposal is to
expand that slowly in terms of he
certain ease a couple more office staff
and potentially a few more people on the
ground as well so the the
additional employment would come from
people that arrived or office based or
out on out out doing rounds but it I
think we're talking four five more at
Mad Max anyway going back to the noise
we haven't gotten noise readings our
proposal at the moment it as the
conditions if recommended is that there
will be mitigation in terms of physical
noise attenuation carried out to the
rear of the residential properties
proposed to buffer that from any noise
from a four-team of course we're going
to need to understand what that noise
level is to know what the mitigation is
and that would form part of our
submission but there isn't a proposal to
buffer the commercial elements because
the rear elevation of the b1 units is a
solid flank wall anyway so that will be
noise insulated so the actual face of
those buildings is into the site rather
than onto a fourteen and actually the
physicality of the buildings themselves
will offer some some buffer to the
residential anyway I just got a quick
question on the hours of operation my
experience of electrical engineers they
normally start very early pick up stuff
about 7:00 7:30 an hour off but it says
here that you won't be accessing the
site late a.m. is that realistic he's we
have we're happy to fit in with with the
conditions in that in that sense I mean
John at the moment you're probably right
in terms of it's probably bit more
flexible where they are in sense of the
restrictions aren't there but but John's
business model is that they can work
from 8 ok thank you and we have we have
to ward members councillor Mike Norris
and councillor Stephen Phillips and I
have something here to read out from
councillor Mike Norris I'm unable to
attend the development control committee
meeting this Wednesday the 26th of June
and would ask you to accept this email
as my comments now being joint Ward
member for Cretans and Mary I have a
number of reservations regarding this
application the parish council objects
this application have expressed their
concerns on page 235 of the report on a
number of issues there is no appropriate
road structure to handle the extra
traffic this application would create
industrial units are how to keep in with
the current development
impact on the appearance of the error as
the site would be visible as elevated
removal of hedges and trees meaning loss
of appearance from wildlife and no
footpath included on the plans which
would lead to health and safety issues
additionally there are considerable
number of neighbors objecting to the
details and this is detailed on page 200
no representations having been recorded
as being in support of the application
within the principle development on page
204 paragraph 3.8 it states in relation
to the provision of commercial
development on this site the land is
clearly not allocated for industrial
purposes in the adopted development plan
and therefore like the residential
development element of the proposal the
scheme would represent a departure from
the plan this is further reiterated with
in paragraph 12.1 on page 210 where it
says as advised previously in this
report the application proposal
represents a departure from the
established land use policies for this
area and that it seeks to introduce
residential and commercial uses on land
it is not allocated for those purposes
within paragraph six point three on page
206 it states the proposed b2 buildings
would undoubtedly have a greater visual
prominence on the site and would be
significantly larger than the
established development in the area this
application as submitted does not appear
to be significantly different to the
previous application DC 1731 47 on the
site which was withdrawn on the 30th of
July 2018 and therefore unable to
support this application in this
location we request a site visit so that
members can assess the site topography
and the highway constraints for
themselves and counselor might Norris
and I have not received anything from
Council Stephen Phipps so that's it
members let's all the information yep
over to us to discuss and debate and
have some answers straight off well I I
didn't actually I'm not quite ready to
start with a baby yet but I just had
another question which relates to the
late papers that we've got from this
Suffolk County Council highways which
talks about the 30 mile an hour speed
limit and I just like a bit of
clarification
pation hear it it sounds as if it's not
compulsory to move the 30 mile an hour
speed limit but it might help things is
that that last a sort of message I get
from this lake paper I know I haven't
really had time to digest it but perhaps
someone could clarify whether we are
having an extension to the 30 mile an
hour limit or not or whether it would be
beneficial and if so how far is that
proposed extension to the 30 mile an
hour limit likely to be I think first if
I'll refer you to page 17 on the table
papers and the comment in response that
might be more helpful in terms of
context where it says the extension of
the speed limit isn't essential to say
enable safe access to developments it's
the case that if you look at the site
there is a speed limit in approximately
the same position as where the proposed
access to the industrial development
would be so in the event that this
development went ahead that speed limit
would have to be moved anyway and it is
suggested by the highway authority as I
understand it that the speed limit will
be shifted down towards flawed andros
junction with the road at the bottom
that you saw on the plan just come back
on that can you also perhaps you could
put up a plan as to where the 30 mile an
hour limit along the main road in
towards the Needham lake is there a 30
million hour limit there where does that
begin because obviously this junction
with floored and road and that road
seems to be the issue and I'm pretty
sure there must be a 30 mile an hour
limit somewhere down that road towards
the river you know can you just point
out where they start and finish I'm
afraid I can't point out the speed limit
you've just identified councillor could
point out the speed limit where it is in
for all them Road at the moment but
that's not the question you are sort of
right so sorry
yeah well I'm just I can't go long
they're pretty reasonably frequently
living in Needham either oh good
just at the junction with Needham Lakes
Thank You chair I think the thing the
thing that strikes me with this
particular application is the the fur
that's currently based on the Apes
Curtis Stone market wants to move to a
larger site which increases more jobs
there also be opportunities for other
jobs in the district and I to do 10
degree with the economic development
officer that we want to encourage jobs
within the district and therefore I'm at
this moment I'm viewing in support of
this application point of view council
mouse thank you
you know whilst I do have a lot of
sympathy with the residents of Florin
Road about the fact that this is an
industrial commercial site adjacent to
some residential dwellings there are
some other sort of commercial operations
further up the road and this this
particular development is at the end of
the road very close to access for the
a14 so from that point of view it's
probably better to have the any
industrial commercial use at that end of
Lordan Road rather than further up
because I realized that we can't insist
that the traffic from the commercial
site is only going to turn left but
presumably most of these electricians
are going to be driving off and they'll
head for the a14 and they won't be going
past the residential dwellings further
along
Florin Road so in that sense it does
seem quite quite a good location in
terms of road access however I'm not
convinced that there's any pedestrian or
safe cycle access to this site and yet
it is really within walking distance of
the railway station and if we're going
to have some little industrial units it
would be great if people could work
there and come on the train and walk now
I realize that they could walk across
the lake and the car boot sale field but
then they come on floored and Road
there's no pavement there anyway so
and consequently there's no no footpaths
on the plan within the site but that
maybe that's a bit before sight I don't
know whether that that can be put in
that probably can't be put in by
condition because that changes the plans
completely so although I in a way I
would quite like to support this site
and if I do support this site I would
like some more conditions added about
environmental sustainability of water
and energy usage and about some sort of
protection for the landscape and
vegetation buffer between the neighbor
but I'm still I'm still a bit concerned
that there isn't any safe walking or
cycle access to the site so I will here
like to hear what my fellow members have
got to say about about this but you know
it is a good thing to promote some
business in the area and I think this is
this is better than some places to put
industrial units so and it's going to be
a bit of mix is going to be three houses
there does seem to be a bit of a buffer
within the site between the houses and
the commercial use so I think some
thought has gone into that but I will
wait to see what I hear what other
people have got to say you want to do
want officers to explore now the two
points you raised on what and what that
would look like so that members would
understand so in terms of the landscape
there are two conditions the one up and
two up from the bottom is approval of a
landscape management plan and a
professor of landscape scheme city exact
detail if that would be something we can
agree by condition in terms of tree
planting how it looks when they get
planted how they're protected all that
kind of thing would be subject to that
condition in terms of sustainable
construction under cs3 we have a
requirement for non-residential
development proposes over a thousand
square metres I have to have integrated
renewable technology given the agent
suggestion there be happy to comply with
something like that I see no reason why
we couldn't agree something like that
under condition which would include
energy water resources how that gets
resolved and normally would suggest a
scheme is to be agreed so that between
us we can agree how that would come
forward so I think you know given what
cs3 suggests and what the agent said
they're happy to do we could secure of
that sorry what was the third point I
think the third point is is conditional
because it was to do with the safe
pedestrian and cycle access which isn't
in the plan so I don't think we can
alter that at this stage I think there
is detail of access is to be provided
under conditions so that might give us
the space to do that under that
condition it is still to be agreed so
that we could look at it we couldn't
necessarily specify it as you say but at
least it would be under that that we
would review that okay
thank you who was next yes
got some ass yeah I mean I I yeah I tend
to think that with enough with enough
conditions and apart from the two that
just been discussed of course we've also
talked about strong noise conditions and
also over the the use of the b2 building
the council mounts was raise the
difficulty which is off site which is
the sustainable travel to the adjacent
town of Needham that's that's a bit the
problem I think that the the other
reservation I've got at the moment
really he said that the if those
particularly those was coming here on
the train will see that an enormous
amount of land has been set out and
groundworks clary doubt and so on for
the next extension of lime barn is huge
we really can't talk about other
possible sites we can only look at the
application before us today we know
that's the number one you know so you
know what may come forward at other
sites it's what is there we have to look
at what's before us today yeah I think I
think it comes back to the to the
conflicting views about whether there's
lots of these units already available or
or that they were all standing empty
that's that's that that's the difficulty
part from that as I said I think I tend
to be supporting it with lots of
conditions
Casa Phil yes
I feel really that this societies sort
of well related to access to the
highways network to the I 14 I am
somewhat concerned sticking to highways
issues environment that the report
suggests even with being a very low
right II first percentile speeds at this
Junction that nevertheless highways are
accepting visibility supplies that are
somewhat less than their recommended
values so I find that a bit of a concern
put it mildly I do recognize that this
road I think has other mixed uses along
it so it's not outlets keeping really or
not knowing consistent with decisions
that we made in the past in fact I think
ones that we've made not so long ago to
allow other mix use along Florin Road I
am a bit concerned against time work
that when we look at the noise controls
that suggested they're all incredibly
woolly there's no actual values in there
it doesn't quote the even that the the
noise emitted in these buildings will
not exceed the current ambient from the
I 14 from whatever it's from so I'm sure
that the conditions are very broad brush
and
and could could result in anything you
care to imagine having said all that lot
what does for you well so the access to
the a14 is quite good and economically
it's clearly good to it and encourage
local businesses that are expanding so I
guess on balance I am for this
development and I don't really know how
I would propose to condition the noise
requirement so that I was actually
comfortable with what I eat resulting
what what I would actually deliver
Justin say I appreciate the bullet
points on page 2 1 1 10 3 5 broad
strokes if you go back to page 2 4 2 & 2
4 3 the suggestions by the environmental
health of a certain respective noise do
go a lot further and I think we're
trying to summarize those in a bullet
point for you and you say our technical
requirements through our summary packs
is a little bit on the port side
hopefully those details of those
conditions give you more certainty
obviously if there are other things
members would like we can add or amend
those conditions following on from what
Gemma said it's condition for
particularly council on page 24 3 which
uses that phrase commercial but does
relate to everything non-residential on
there is basically saying plant
equipment machinery can't exceed
decibels above the background noise
level so they would need to be
attenuation in place which secured that
level of noise within each individual
unit b1 and b2 so hopefully that would
give you some comfort
thank you know you've just discovered
the page I didn't read there's a
confession for you
yes that does seem to tie it down fairly
adequately cancer having him considering
all that's been said I'm happy to
propose that we go along with the
officers recommendation for approval
with the conditions that we all decide
on you know Gemma can come up with them
and so go along with them the
environment oh thank you yep customer
Thank You chair I'm happy to second case
of having a mr. proposal doesn't no one
else wish to speak counsel maths yeah on
the landscaping on it I think
presumably the one page two to two now
presumably that the the black the black
blobs are are existing landscaping just
get yes and the gray the gray the new
planning I mean I think it's it's and
coming back to the objectors point it is
striking that the existing hedge Eames
where it ends
and the if you wanted to extend that
hedge then that that house is a bit too
near the red line which which i think is
i think the landscaping condition which
needs to address that properly can I say
I'm just Gemma's just gonna she's saying
yes so that the entirety of the scheme
in terms of protecting existing trees
everything they proposed that is
landscaping both hard and soft
landscaping that is what we would
normally expect to be dealt with by that
condition
I appreciate the bullet point is quite
short but the condition itself that we
use is actually quite long and quite
detailed on that so it should secure all
those details
yes if there's a particular areas of
concern we could add that to our
condition if you would like are we okay
to move the house a couple of metres if
we need to cancer man sir
can we can we I know we can't put speed
limits as part of a condition but
obviously we've had this bit about the
fact the signs got to move because
that's where the entranceway is going to
be can we put some advisory on about
it perhaps extending the 30 mile an hour
spin speed limit further so that it
actually covers that junction where
we've recently had a fatality because I
don't know whether we can we could do
anything about that
it's what's reasonable and necessary to
secure this development rather than
anything else it is part of into into a
unilateral undertaking is to see what we
can see but it's got through related to
this development sirs it's what the
Highways Authority advised us on that
one said anyone else wish to speak I'm
going to be the difficult one I'm afraid
I don't agree with anyone's said because
I think it's a massive conflict at b2
next to residential and I suspect in
times coming forward we'll have the
people have moved in there knocking on
our door saying there's too much noise
coming from the site and I don't think
having timescales of 8 to 5:30 is
realistic either I think you'll find
that will very soon get complaints I
think there's too much of a conflict and
I think it doesn't go with the local
plan so I hear what everyone else says
but I'm afraid I'll be the difficult one
and won't be supporting it so we'll go
to a vote all those in favor of the
recommendation with all the additional
points that have been raised by accounts
of man sort of Matheson that had been
added into the proposal around landscape
management plan the landscape scheme the
energy efficiency which is within that
and the extension of the hedging all the
way through and that it's all units
rather than commercial industrial units
so all in favor of the recommendation as
previously discussed come have a show of
hands please six bears against
that is carrot okay we now move on to
the final item of today which is agenda
item the DC 1901 67 3 which is
agricultural crop drying building in the
water Stradbroke and lacks field of
barley brick farmer
okay so over to you
thank you Thank You chair yes the
application we've got in front of us is
for the erection of an agricultural rock
drying barn it's located on barley brick
farm maxfield Road painting straw Brook
we move forward we've got the scale down
map here the small orange dot sort of
l-shaped in the center of the screen is
the application site you can see
Stradbroke yeah you can see strut Brook
and down this way we get into lakhs
field if we move on to the aerial we've
still got the orange out in the in the
middle of the screen this is the
council's aerial mapping we've got the
neighboring farm immediately adjacent
and then to the north we've got some
existing lagoons there's a now there's
two anaerobic digesters serving the site
located here that's not shown on our
aerial mapping and then there's a number
of agricultural our buildings here as
well
[Applause]
slightly slightly scaled in it just jump
ahead in terms of planning history
apologies and I didn't realize when I
was creating the slide that that writer
would be so small there's a number of
things to bear in mind in 2015 there was
a waste application made to Suffolk
County Council on the site for the
current anaerobic digesters associate
infrastructure and use of the
agricultural lagoons as part of the
anaerobic digesters on site that was
approved subject to conditions 1837 17
was an application for erection of a
croc drying barn that was granted
permission subject to conditions that
permission is still live and I'll go
into what was permitted there a little
later we have then had application DC
1902 zero eight seven and that's an
application made under schedule to part
6 if the general permitted development
order for the erection of an
agricultural building for crop drying
because that application has made under
permit development rights the use of the
barn is limited in some respects and
that it can't be used for keeping of
livestock and it cannot be used for
storage or slurry or sewage but the GP
do is fairly clear that we can't impose
other conditions that is materially
similar to the application we have
before us the big difference here in
terms of planning histories although we
can't condition and control the use of
the barn under the permitted development
option we can exercise some control
through the use of conditions here to
pick up on comments from the Parish
Council with regards to some EAA scoping
opinion applications that were received
by the council for a combined I think 12
and 7 poultry sheds we have barley brick
farm up here and then apology I couldn't
get the map to show I wanted in a very
good color but down here we have
Southport Road
and then further down in the bottom
corner we have the application for seven
poultry sheds around here and then
twelve was up here so that's just to
give members an idea of the the
proximity to Bali brick farm of those
applications so when we discuss it later
we can bring that forward I would just
know that those are AI scoping opinions
only no planning applications have been
received for those sites and when they
do come forward they'll need to be
supported by any IAEA development and
will also likely have to come before
committee for approval this is just
something else I think will be useful
for members to have in front of them
this is a map showing agricultural and
waste anaerobic digesters within the
area the blue diamond sort of central
that is body briggs digester the others
are all other digesters within within
the area the the blue circles and
diamonds indicate agricultural die das
digesters the green circles environments
indicate waste digesters the barley burg
digester is agricultural in use and the
diamonds just denotes that it provides
centrally empower for use on the site
circular notes sites that produce
biomethane the feed into the gas grid
provide power to the National Grid now
if we move on to the application at hand
here is a site location plan the
familiar orange l-shape justice give
members an idea of constraints it's
within triple si impact zone in
researching the triple si itself it
identifies likely impact from
development including livestock and
poultry sheds greater than 500 square
metres slurry recurred lagoons greater
than 750 square metres manure stores
that we store more than 3,500 times you
know this is the block plan of the
development we have an existing barn
here this is already on site and access
down the side
these are the anaerobic digesters here
and then we have the existing lagoons
and buildings that you saw previously
this is the proposed bar with some
landscaping around the side here these
are the elevations and internal floor
plans very barn-like
if we move on sorry to a comparison with
1837 17 apologies in these comparisons
I'm not quite being able to get the the
scales right but I've got them as close
as we can and I think members can see
that the difference between yes
definitely so this is the current
proposed proposal for the smaller barn
this quite there's quite a gap here to
the access ramp to the back in the
anaerobic digester this is the storage
barn that has extant permission so it
could be built out subject to compliance
with existing conditions it expands
beyond the scope of the existing but
quite some quite some way here the here
in the elevations it in terms of
materials and appearance it's similar to
one we're considering at the moment but
then it is a large agricultural building
and those carry connotations of an
agricultural scale of architecture this
is the application again so the left is
the current proposed plant the right is
what is allowed under DC 1902 oa7
which is permitted development they are
similar in size there is a slight
setback here at the frontage and here
are the comparison side-by-side of
what's proposed so what is proposed
before is it is at the top so it's
slightly longer slightly larger but in
terms of appearance materially similar
to to what we have before us today
if I pass over to two members I'll
answer any questions that arises reports
do you want to jump in it was just for
clarification that paragraph 1.3 minute
since 1837 or 17 included a straw burner
and that element was withdrawn from that
presence they don't have been sent for
it
it's just a barn as Daniel's just
explained but I just wanted to clarify
that specifically from that paragraph
you've got consent for the barn
they're now applying for the barn again
so just that is a mistake that we need
that is effectively there's a some
wording in 1.3 that shouldn't be there
that we've now hopefully explained that
to members satisfaction can you just
just send room st. clear just just just
just for absolute clarity can you just
run through what they've got permission
for and what is the difference between
what they've got mission for and what is
before us in just the real detail in the
difference thank you so if we go back on
the on the presentation slightly so
thank you so on the right here is what
they have permission for for a large
storage barn the straw burner and
external ventilation was removed as part
of negotiations with planning officers
at the time of that application so at
the moment this barn can be used for
storage purposes only and then we have
really we're saying is we're going from
a large barn to a large farm that has
crop drying ability and that is the
different noise though so the the size
is not that dissimilar it's just the
fist is the purpose of the building is
what we're being really asked to
consider help
but it's clear now yeah good counselor
man sir
thank you food truck laughs I don't get
my head around this either and I'm still
baffled as to what the poultry sheds
have got to do with it I mean there is a
scoping application for potential
chicken sheds and there is speculation I
understand from the Parish Council and
from there is speculation out there
which is speculation speculation that
this will be the feeding facility for
the chicken shirts but there is no
application for tricular sheds nothing
has come forward there is only a scoping
exercise so it's so it's the scoping is
not the same size it's a dimension
there's some distance away
I think the query had been wood what is
dried in this coat I can't say go and
feed those chickens I think in other
references we might the drying of the
chickens there which is not boys
intended I don't quite sure where that
reference council this is for drying or
agricultural crops and we could control
that by condition if members have got
particular concerns about that the
community is is associating this with a
possible application but the problem the
thing we have to remember here is we can
only look at the application is before
us at this moment in time and anything
else is really not to be tied into it
yeah counts a man so hot and so what is
the link is there any link between the
proposed crop drying shed on this site
and the aerobic digester which is behind
the exists that was this site have
clarity on that because we've also had
different things about that so can you
describe thank you so in terms of the
crop drying at present they don't have
any crop growing facilities on site so
the present crops are being taken from
the farm in HGVs
transported off site to be dried and
then transport it back by HDTV to be fed
into the digester having the facility
on-site would mean that you can move per
you know you can remove a number of HTV
movement both to and from the sigh so
they could dry the crop crop residue on
site and then use it to feed the
anaerobic digester the existing shed
that is adjacent to the one that we're
discussing today is that also a crop
drying shed or is that some other sort
of storage shed I don't I don't believe
it has crop drying facilities although I
believe the agent is here so maybe we
could direct the question to get
something definitive from it yeah just
just just an issue I understood from the
papers that the crop drawing that would
take place here he's sort of turning the
crop over on the floor something he's
not a forced fan driven drawing process
am i understanding that properly so that
means little noise associated other than
reversing believers on JCB's or whatever
he caught him in the farming world the
the the other issue was I just
discovered from the last questioner I
don't really understand the the
relationship with the anaerobic digester
I assumed that was for well to dispose
of residue from crops but it's a bit
difficult to see your comment just was
at currently they're shipping crop away
from the farm for drawing in some one
remote facility shipping it back and you
then said I'm feeding it into the
anaerobic digester that's I can
understand feeding it into chickens but
for he did it into a digester seems
Luna T I could understand you he you
know the residue we've got here so we
can ask them just be interesting to
fully understand what we're told as the
applicants and any other questions at
this point on the presentation and the
commendations before us no okay so again
keyboards yes yeah so just within the
the report that's been provided
strawberryk counsel I think in their
representations provided the copy of the
2015 Suffolk County Council waste
application and they know condition 1415
sorry a certain number of feedstocks
that can be brought in for use in the UH
narrow with digesters on-site which
include energy crops sugar beet pulp
apple pulp a chicken litter herbs this
is page 285 so I mean I think when we
are talking about crops we need to be
careful in that we are thinking
potentially about different things that
are being fed so there are certain crops
are particularly good in anaerobic
digesters and potentially might be
growing on a site when you are using an
anaerobic digester just to have there
and have available to you I think also
we are also sort of thinking recently as
sort of lay people that actually crop is
something that you know we would either
feed to animals or we ourselves as well
and I think the use of of crop probably
encapsulates both of those so just to be
careful and avoid any disassociation
there I also know and doing background
research just to talk about poultry
sheds again although the current
anaerobic digesters on site or allowed a
certain tonnage of chicken litter within
capacity every 12 months in researching
anaerobic digesters it it's become
apparent that actually chicken lived it
was quite acidic and in order to produce
that passed that through an anaerobic
digester you have to quite carefully
monitor many levels they used that I
don't know where they are in terms of
their current capacity and again the
aging can probably elaborate on that in
of chicken weights but I imagine that if
they were close to capacity we'd then be
looking at further applications to
Suffolk County Council to either alter
that conditional or alter the anaerobic
digesters but again that's a
consideration for the waist authority
and not for us unfortunately okay
any other questions at this point yeah
so we don't have anyone from the parish
council doing no just a point I have
received I was informed that a member of
the parish council mr. Chris Edwards was
going to turn up today he has sent me
something but I've spoke to probably
read I've spoken to mr. Duprey and we're
in agreement that under the public
speaking rules that we wouldn't we can't
read out anything further from what
received but it wasn't but we can't yeah
they get to respond which is in our
papers which is we've seen the pictures
of the chicken and the other things in
our papers say that is an additional one
yes that was sent last week just shortly
after the papers were published so that
is an extra representation from the
parish in there but there's another one
that has been received this morning and
with regards to it okay so we'll now
move on so we've moved to mr. Stephen
Bainbridge who is the applicant or the
agent and if you'd like to come up and
you have three minutes good afternoon
councillors my name is Stephen bein rich
from Parker planning I'm a member of the
RTP I like your planning officers I've
worked on this planning application I'm
a former baby planning officer if that
counts in my favor
and there was agent agent for the body
Bridge ad plant regularization
application approved in 2015 in this
room I was involved in the recent
environmental information regulations
request about feedstocks to that plant
that was made by the Parish Council
we've put two applications in for the
drying barn the prior approval that
you've been told about and this planning
application the prior approval has been
granted and your planning officer says
this is a significant material
consideration in this application so in
other words we are 95% of the way there
on this application I've made comments
about some of the proposed planning
conditions hopefully appreciate that
would be remiss of me not to ask you to
consider those comments and to consider
dis applying some of the planning
additions as you go through debate there
are very minor differences between the
applications the effect being that when
one is implemented the other cannot be
this fact should answer some or one of
the parish councils concerns the
planning application red line is
constrained to the site so does not
confer a linkage to the ad plant I have
read the consultation responses and the
newspaper article weather aware the
various concerns being voiced but
support the planning officers assessment
of the relevant planning matters one
matter I'd like to raise is traffic and
the neighborhood plan we appreciate what
local communities say about traffic when
it comes to individual planning
applications and of course where
relevant
transport assessments are required
however whilst the neighborhood plan
talks about HGV levels and traffic
congestion on the beach over 1/8 and the
beach of 1/7
what it does not do and I did a word
search for it is mentioned at all
anywhere that Stradbroke is a junction
of the approved Suffolk County lorry
route network that's the important thing
for the council to bear in mind in
relation to this application or indeed
any in strobe brook by traffic and HGV
impacts or a matter of concern in
concern in terms of addressing the thin
end of the wedge concerns the applicant
that suggested their condition limiting
the combined maximum rated output of the
grain dryers to four megawatts thermal
so if you have any questions about the
drawing barns the ad plant or any of the
other stuff I do my best to answer thank
you very much any questions can't some
answer I'm still a little bit confused
about all that all of what's going on
but can you tell me where the stuff
that's going into this barn is coming
from and where it's going to after it's
been dried in the barn or whatever it's
doing in there and what the relevant
amount of traffic that's going to be
bringing stuff in and taking stuff out
from this particular bomb shared drying
room whatever you want to call okay the
material the crops are coming in from
rattler farms farm land holding locally
and then potentially other farms locally
you wouldn't count that stuff too far in
terms of where the material goes the
planning statement we submitted sets out
that the challenges and the materials
and where they come from so we have a
wheat grown on the farm and providing
feed to own pigs we brought in from
other farms and providing feed to own
pigs they were a very large group of
sheds you saw on the aerial photos
oil seed rape grown on the farm and sold
on to others wet straw grown on the farm
and used as own Pig bedding that toes
weights coming from where it's going to
I think the issue about the crops coming
into this building and going to the ad
plant I don't think that's the case
because these feeds or these
so items here don't match with the
approved list of feedstocks for the ad
plan anyone else have any questions nope
okay
thank you very much and next we go to
the ward member which is cancer
Julie Flatman and she sent in the
following please accept a walk member
for the committee please accept my
apologies for not attending in person
today but I have teaching commitments I
have asked that the application was
brought to committee because of the
County Council Parish Council and
residents concern on environment from
cumulative impact firstly residents are
concerned the site will be taking more
waste than can be safely processed
that's causing environmental harm
including noise air pollution and
drainage problems on the site secondly
increased traffic through local through
local villages and on ancient roads not
built for heavy traffic I must state I'm
in full support of our farming and the
production of English produce we need to
be as self-sufficient as possible
especially in the wider political
climate we find ourselves in at present
we should reducing our import of food
with its implications on soaring costs
and carbon footprint the concerns of
increased waste from newly proposed
poultry farm nearby cannot be considered
this is not yet a live application
however you should be aware that this
has been included by the parish council
and the concerns of around this have
been raised by the county councillor I
would ask the committee to look at all
the evidence and if not sure to defer
the application for further
investigation if minded to pass the
application please consider condition
for a traffic plan to ensure drivers
come through the villages at lower than
30 miles an hour
especially past the schools and where
possible loop the route to minimize
through traffic this has been
accomplished in other rural areas Thank
You chair and members Julie flatten
so members we've had all the information
put before us
we've had the views of the parish
council before us and we've heard from
the agent as well so and from the ward
member so every to us to discuss and
debate counselor field then counselor
Madison indeed sound familiar so there
are some misconceptions about the flow
of materials through this barn taking
the agent of statements particularly it
seems that we are talking about a
variety of products which will be draw
it for feed purposes or bidding purposes
and they will partially come from the
count the actual farm and partly from
other surrounding farms but it didn't
sound as others any waste you know
anything coming in which will be
processed in this barn to make it more
suitable for or to increase the flour
into the anaerobic digesters as seem to
worry people one can totally understand
people's concerns about traffic volumes
but it sounds rather as though those
volumes exist at the moment some of them
may be redirected so it strikes me that
this is the sort of development that is
necessary to support the farming
industry and the which is a significant
industry and suffer but that there needs
to be some constraint upon traffic
routes it takes which the conventional
way to do that is where some sort of
travel transport plan that basically and
gets the the operator of the barn to
ensure that people delivering materials
to him or taking materials from him go a
sensible route which might include not
going past the primary school at nine
o'clock in the morning or some similar
so my feeling is that we should accept
this application but insists that there
is a requirement for sensible transport
plan that constrains that as far as one
can the behaviors that the local
residents are concerned about the driver
behaviour and one always recognizes that
such plans are difficult to enforce but
if they don't exist they're even more
difficult to enforce something called it
HGB delivery schedule you can draw up
was anything like that that exists I
have it in the back of my mind there is
a Sofia suffer glory route network
that's provided by Suffolk County
Council there is a HTV delivery delivery
plan condition there is recommended by
by the Highways Authority under the
recommendation for a new I'd seen it
somewhere it's under the recommendation
yes it's under there onto the
recommendation that there is a delivery
management plan put in place through the
condition councillor Matson you Annette
yeah thank you yeah now I've managed to
read page 21 of the late papers this
that the Chris Edwards we said wasn't
that the name yet he he's making a
couple of points that I think I'd like
to hear what the officers have got to
say about really one apart from the
equivalent about the the weather the
drawings are quite right which I don't
understand the significance of the the
challenge is that the County rather than
the district as the Waste Authority
waste planning authority ought to be
judging this which is an interesting
fundamental and then then the third
point is that a Freedom of Information
request on the County has shown that the
traffic movements related to the
digester are far and the farm site
our exceed the the the planning consent
transport assessment by a huge margin
that's quite worried especially you know
we can't say feel talking about travel
plans funny enough when that came in
that was we've asked I asked we've asked
officers to look at that and Gemma's got
some answers
yep so we've been in discussion with
County about that and they have
clarified and this is our point as well
is that we don't believe and we don't
consider that there is a relationship
between the bio digester and that but
and the specific word is from County at
the moment there is no relationship
between the development for the bio
digester and that being considered by
MSD C tomorrow a giant ship the adjacent
farm so they are clear and we are
satisfied that these are two separate
entities and therefore we are entitled
to consider this isn't a cultural
building any implications for the bio
digester that goes above and beyond the
consent they have would trigger
requirements with County in terms of Vic
EULA movements I think where we are at
for this one is currently the cops from
the farm leave the farm they go off and
are dried elsewhere and they are
actually mimic the movements associated
with that whereas with this one we're
talking about them being permanently
dried from this site so we'd have to
consider actually is there a reduction
in HCV movement appreciating the point
in terms of HD movements for the bio
digester that is subject to its own
separate controls and the information I
have at the county is that they are
reviewing the situation with the bio
digester and assessing compliance with
the conditions that they are subject to
at the moment so they are looking into
there aspects of the planning from
county waste purposes and we need to
consider it from our point of view with
the add cultural and that's yeah I think
that's that's that's all very very
helpful to be assuring that they
probably also points up what what the
first of these points is about as to
whether the two things are so close
together that we should consider them as
one
or not and you've you satisfied with the
drawings on that basis yeah I think we
have to with the drawings we've accepted
than previously we've reviewed them
dancers have been out in sight and had a
look as well so we content they're
sufficiently separate from that point of
view and they have separate purposes and
this doesn't have a specific waist
purpose it has a purpose for
agricultural crop dyeing whatever that
copies and whatever its future purpose
at the point it's dried it's an
agricultural crop its agricultural
related and therefore that's how we deal
with it under this application okay
councillor Mansell thank you yeah I am I
think counts the field this actually
said quite a lot of what I was going to
say and that it appears to me from from
what the agent has said is that the this
this crop drying barn has the potential
to reduce the traffic going to this farm
because they're going to be have an
on-site facility to to dry their crops
and use it for their pigs or whatever so
and I think that the the objections have
all muddied the water with this
confusion and linked with the aerobic
digester and the proposed possible
pie-in-the-sky that aren't there yet
poultry sheds and it's just made it all
so confusing but it's quite hard to get
your head round so so yeah I mean I I
think that that yet if there is a
transport plan for the movement of the
crops that do come from elsewhere that
would be great which seems to be one of
the conditions and I think we also have
to remember that they've already got
permission to put a bigger shed here
anyway
so I really think that if we refuse this
and there's gonna be anything bigger
shared so that's potentially going to
have more crops being dried in it and
where are they all going to come from so
I I think I think that
then we need to be clear that the
previous Bush is not for croc drying is
for storage but but even so there's
story I'm just being clear but okay
they're gonna store some sub crops there
they've got to come from somewhere I
mean III do think it is a bit I'm not a
masseur I was thoroughly confused and
I'm not sure I've quite exact got it
clear in my head but I do think that
this this may reduce the HDTV movements
and we seem to have been assured that it
has nothing to do with aerobic digester
which is on the site so I'm inclined to
support this application but perhaps or
let other people speak before we go to a
proposal Johnny you don't mean that you
want to come back or no yeah if we can
find a second anyone else supposed to
speak I mean I think I mean I do
represent the areas where the chicken
buildings are being talked about but
that is only IA assessment at this point
so you know obviously we've been sent
all the details by the parish and all
the concerns around it but the problem
is we have to look at what's before us
today and they have permission for a
larger building doing a slightly
different purpose this is about crop
drying we're only being asked to decide
on a crop drying facility today despite
all the other things that might be going
around it so I understand the concerns
but I think from a planning reason with
what's before us now I'll fill my author
will be supporting this so no one else
wishes to speak okay so we'll go to a
vote all those in favor of the officers
recommendation show of hands please
that's unanimous thank you very much
there's no other urgent business if I
just ask people to make sure they hand
their white cards back and take their
cups coffee cups with them as well thank
you very much